barton paulson is a university professor
and excellent instructor
in this course he will turn you into an
expert in google sheets
spreadsheets are a lot more useful than
many people think
and don't forget to like and subscribe
to the freecodcamp.org youtube channel
welcome to google sheets what i want to
tell you is that data
loves spreadsheets and that really you
could learn to love them too
now you may not think of yourself as a
data kind of person
but the important thing to know about
data is no matter what you do
data gives you a map it helps you find
your way and
you may wonder a map to what well that
depends on what your
goals are they might be professional
organizational
social personal political but whatever
it is you're interested in
data can help you do it better for
instance if you have a business it can
help you figure out what work that you
do
is most popular with paying clients it
can help you figure out what brings
people back to your non-profit
organization
it can help you say what attracts new
people to your political organization
it may help you figure out what's the
best use of time in your own personal
life
and it can even help you figure out
important questions like how much should
you charge for your work or your
services
so data is a method of approaching
any one of these questions but
what does that have to do with google
sheets well google sheets
lets you do several different things
that are really important
with data first and foremost google
sheets
gives your data a home now you know
where your stuff is and you can find it
you can search for it you can share it
with other people
you get it centralized and now you can
do something
useful with it and you know then what
what are those things that you're going
to do
well there's a few things that you can
do with google sheets that are really
helpful number one is you can graph your
data
you can explore your data think of
yourself as an explorer you're out there
in really a new area and you're trying
to find out what's all around you and
what's the best way forward in google
sheet
you can do that with graphs like this
multiple variable timeline
it can help you find the places of
greatest
value and help lead you in that
particular direction
google sheets can also help you sort and
filter through your
data now you got a collection of tea
bags
put them in little boxes it makes it
easier to see what you have and also to
see what you're missing
in the data world you can sort
your data by whatever categories you
want you can
filter it here i'm filtering by a couple
of different categories
if you've got a business you can find
new clients
that are in your database and focus on
them or you can find
open accounts and you can focus on them
and take care of it
and once you find the data that's most
important to you you can calculate
things about that data
and you can summarize it really it's a
way of bringing
things into focus the entire
point of data analysis is to simplify
things
in a way that helps you reach practical
goals you want to bring it into focus
sometimes the focus analogy really can
be pretty literal
here i have a set of almost 1400 numbers
and
it's completely overwhelming but over
here on the right you can see that the
mean
the average is 547.5 and the maximum is
9.99
i've got conditional formatting that
highlights where those 999s are
and also where the minimum values of 100
are it helps you
sort through the haystack and find the
needles are going to be of most
use to you finally believe it or not
spreadsheets and google sheets can help
you work creatively
now not necessarily to create your own
art but if you're an artist you will
find out that google sheets
can help you free up some time and some
cognitive bandwidth to focus on the
things that are most important to you
and you can be creative in spreadsheets
here's one that i use when planning a
big trip around the world with my family
i actually had to get a spreadsheet to
help figure out who is going to sit
where on all of the plane rides or you
can use a spreadsheet
to help you make a decision about what
you want to focus on in your business to
help you reach both your personal
and professional goals i'll give you
examples of all of these things and as
you go through the course
you can follow along by downloading the
files that we have
at this address datalab.cc
tools slash gsh that stands for google
sheets
zero one so that's datalab.cc slash
tools slash gsh01
download the sheets follow along and
really
try google sheets and what you'll find
is that it's gonna help you
listen to your data and find your way in
your own work
thanks for joining me i'm excited to
have you here and i'm excited to hear
from you
about how working with data in a simple
tool like google sheets can help you
find better value in your own work
before we really get started in this
course there's one important piece of
advice
i always have to tell everybody and that
is
when you're working with data always
do pictures first the idea is you want
to take a look at your data
see what's in front of you get the
context get the big picture
maybe zoom in on some smaller things but
you need to start
with a visual analysis in other words
first graphs then
numbers as far as i'm concerned the
graphs are the analysis and the numbers
are simply a way of lending precision
to the numbers i always tell my students
when i teach statistics
that every single thing we do in the
class
can be done visually you can graph it
or you can calculate it with numbers
that's possible too but
graphs and visuals come first
now i can't talk about this without
sharing the world's best known example
within the statistics community
it's called anscombe's quartet a
statistician charles antscom
back in the 70s somehow found a set of
data that did something very unusual
we have four small sets of data here and
what you need to see
is that these summary statistics on the
bottom the sample size the mean that's
the average the standard deviation a
measure of how spread out things are
the correlation between the two
variables
and the regression equation with the
slope and the intercept
see those numbers right there they're
the same as those numbers right there
are the same as those numbers right
there are the same as those numbers
right there
so based on a cursory
numerical analysis these four data sets
are identical
on the other hand when you graph it you
see it doesn't really hold up
here's the first set of data this is a
nice normal
looking regression equation things are
scattered around a little bit
on this line this is what we're
expecting in regular analysis
on the other hand the second pair of
variables has this
really clear but curved relationship
now the kind of analysis we usually do
is looking for straight lines because
that's the simplest possible way of
describing an association between two
things
you can draw a straight line through
this but you're doing damage to the
relationship because really you need to
be modeling the curve
there are ways to do that but they're
relatively advanced and
personally i've never had to deal with
them
the third set of variables you see we've
got this really strong straight line but
we've got
one number boop that's popping up and
it's an outlier
and the immediate question is what's
going on with that number why is it out
of line
because if you're doing for instance a
manufacturing process that might
indicate something's broken
it might just be a sensor that would be
nice but it could be something about
the manufacturing process again our
standard approach doesn't
deal well with outliers and anomalies
and so
you got to be careful about that and
then the last one set for is a
very bizarre really kind of a
pathological data set
where all of the numbers are jammed over
here on the left
with this one extreme outlier on the
right which would normally be
an indication that something has gone
terribly terribly
wrong in the data gathering and so
simply by looking at them you can see
that there's an enormous
difference even though based on common
statistical measures
they were identical now
these are artificial datasets charles
anscombe had to work very hard
to find these four sets of data but
diverged
so much graphically but closer to real
life there are other reasons why you
would want to do a
graphical analysis first so for instance
take this
this is potential data about donations
to a non-profit organization by month
and you can see that on the left side
things are motoring along kind of fine
about five thousand bucks a month great
and then
suddenly halfway through it more than
doubles
and it settles down a little bit then it
goes up another ten thousand and it
settles down then it goes up another ten
000 and then it drops by 50 percent
the graphical analysis just a simple
line here
lets you know we've got things going on
and we need to figure out
what's making it jump up at each of
these times because maybe we can do more
of that
and then also what's making it drop off
so much at the end
this is the way that even a visual
analysis
can guide the follow-up questions and
can guide
the actions that you take within your
organization
as a way of better understanding
what's happening and allowing you to
maximize
your effectiveness and your efficiency
in reaching your own
goals and besides there's another thing
people are very good at visual analysis
it's a
high information density medium
and so by getting a picture by getting
visuals
you're going to get a lot more insight
than you could with simple tables of
numbers
and so the moral of all of this is
simply always
start by looking remember begin with
graphs and then
follow them up with any numerical
analysis that you want to do
in doing so you'll get a lot more
insight and you'll avoid a lot more
problems on the way of getting to
the information that you need if we're
going to be on the same page and
understand what we're talking about in
here we need to talk a little bit about
the
anatomy of a spreadsheet so the
vocabulary
that i use when describing it can make
some sense first thing is
the actual document that we're in in
google sheets
is just called a spreadsheet in
microsoft excel is called a workbook
and a spreadsheet can consist of more
than one page
each of which has a tab down here at the
bottom
in excel these are called worksheets and
then google sheets they're just called
sheets
and that's where you actually do your
work now each sheet
consists of a number of columns vertical
columns
that have letters to indicate what
column you're in
this is column d right here and they
have rows that are numbered
row number one row number two and what
that means is that
at the intersection of each column and
each row
is a cell so right here i've got
one cell that's one box one data
container
within a google sheet that can put
something in it
and it has an address this is cell
b2 so you always give the
column name letter first that's b in
this case
and the row number second b2 this here
is c3
this right here is b6 this is a4
and so that's the address you have
cells that make a spreadsheet that are
arranged in
vertical columns and horizontal rows now
there's a lot of other things you can do
here one thing is i showed you you can
have multiple
tabs and those allow you to have
different kinds of information
or arrange things in different ways on
each one
each tab also has a little drop down
arrow right next to it that allows you
to do things like duplicate the tab or
change the color of the tab there we go
now we've got a little bit of color
right there i'm going to turn that off
actually
or to see a list of all the tabs that's
good if you've got a lot of them or to
add a new tab
add a sheet and then when you come up to
the top
of the spreadsheet now a lot of times
the first row is for the
names of the columns the variable names
and you might want that to stay where it
is so if you scroll up it doesn't
disappear
you can do that by freezing a row or you
can also freeze
columns and that means that they will
stay there now there's a few different
ways to do that
one of them is to come up here to view
and hit freeze
and say the first row or the first two
rows or wherever i am right now
and columns i personally find it easier
to come over here and get this little
thick line right here and when it turns
into a hand you just
click on that and drag it down and now
the thick line is right here and you can
see that when i scroll up and down
that first row will stay put you can do
the same thing with
columns if you want for instance this
one to always show
column a just come over here
until you i have a little hand and then
drag it over
and now column a will always show
and that's called freezing rows and
columns and it's a way
of making it easier to navigate your
spreadsheet
also when you come up to the top here
you'll find that you have a little drop
down menu
that shows up in each of these including
the ability to sort an entire sheet by
values in a column
so i can click this and now it sorts the
entire sheet
by this column right here if i want to
get back to where i was i could either
do
undo or i could just come and sort by a
different variable
i sort by id sort from ascending
values from a to z you can also sort
descending that's from z to a
you also have a number of toolbars up
here those are familiar with any other
program you've been using there is one
special function i do want to draw to
your attention
and that is way down here in the bottom
corner
we have something that sometimes called
the quick sum box and what it is
let me highlight a few numbers here
i've highlighted some numbers and now
when i come down here
you'll see it gives me the sum i
actually use this a lot if i'm putting
in
dollars i'm putting in values i can get
an immediate sum by just dragging over a
few numbers
and getting their total you can also
click on it and see a whole lot of other
things
the average the minimum maximum the
count the number of scores and the
number of
numbers there's only numbers here so
we're fine
but that's a way to get immediate
information without even having to write
a formula
so the important thing is a spreadsheet
consists
of individual sheets or pages each of
which has cells that are arranged into
vertical columns which are named with
letters
and horizontal rows which are named with
numbers
and as we go through the other videos in
this course you'll see there's a
huge number of things you can do within
each document in google sheets
more than anything a spreadsheet like
google sheets is a container
for data and one of the important things
to remember is that data comes in
lots of different forms a lot of it's
numerically based
but even then you can format it in many
different ways and there is also
non-numeric data and google sheets can
handle
a huge amount of this and i want to show
you some of those variations
so you know what you can put in and
adapt to your own purposes
the most obvious one of course is just
plain old numbers
like this integer 1587 you put those in
there
google sheets will usually put them
flush right text is usually flush left
you can type those in you can get a lot
out of just
those kinds of counting numbers
on the other hand you can also get
proportions which are red
like percentages so this is 0.87
is the same as 87 percent in fact if you
want to see it as a percentage
you can just take that proportion and
you can click here on the format as
percent key
and there it is it even gives you two
decimal places but it's obviously 87
you also have the option of just typing
it in as
87 i'll do it like this
and that also works as a percent if i
press the percent sign there now you see
how it works
now there's one thing you don't want to
do and that is type in the number 87 and
then think if you do this it's going to
turn it into 87 percent it turns it into
8 700
which is obviously not what you want so
you need to start with a proportion the
0.87 and it turns it into percentages
you can also put in a number like pi and
you can decrease the decimals which is
good because
pi has infinite decimals so we can make
a little smaller if you want
or if you have a number with a lot of
decimals already entered
and i'm using the pi function here you
can increase the decimals i don't know
that you really need a lot more but
they're available if you want them now
often
the information you're going to be
entering into a spreadsheet is going to
be financial you can have money you're
going to be keeping track of purchases
and payments
and you have several different options
one is
the accounting format so if you're an
accountant you're familiar with this
but you come up to format to number
and then come down here to accounting
and
what it does is it puts the comma in for
the thousands
it puts the dollar sign way over here
okay
that's pretty easy you can also do
financial formatting which is
similar in certain ways i'll come down
here
and you'll see it puts in the comma but
otherwise it
doesn't have the dollar sign and it
formats a little bit differently
and there's also currency and you
can set your local currency in google
sheets
i'm going to use dollars that's where i
am and so you can see
now it puts a little bit differently and
it's three different ways of
representing the same information
now i realize they're slightly different
from each other
it becomes a little more pronounced when
you make the numbers negative
so i'm going to put a negative there and
now you see it puts it in parentheses
that's a common thing in accounting
and with financial it also puts it in
parentheses but when i come to currency
when i put a negative it sticks in front
of the dollar sign
so a few different ways of dealing with
money depending on
what's the most common practice in the
work that you do
you can also put in dates you just type
them in 7
16 it'll format them and then i'll show
you in another video
there's a lot you can do with dates in
google sheets
and you can also use time so for
instance 10 10 31 just
enter it as hours and then colon
minutes colon and seconds
so those are all numbers and there's a
lot of things you can do with numbers
but google sheets is able to handle a
lot more than that it's able to handle
well for instance it can handle text
so you can just type in words and it
turns out there's a lot of functions
that allow you to
deal with words and i'll give you
examples of those in a later movie
you can put in web links if you type in
a valid web address i just typed in
datalab.cc my address
it recognizes that as http
although it should be https because i
have an ssl
certificate and those are live links you
can click on them
and it'll take you there so here for
instance i have
my website datalab now opening because i
had it
here in the cell the same thing works
you can put email addresses in there
it'll work a lot of different ways you
can put
web data this is an interesting one this
is a special function
that calls in google finance data so
this is
today's stock price for google
1066 dollars a share and
by the way notice we get this little uh
disclaimer down here at the bottom
if i were to delete that the disclaimer
would go away
of course you can use formulas and i've
used a few of them already and have a
lot more say about
formulas so for instance the formula
that pulls up this data is
google finance and then in parentheses
and
[Music]
quotation marks goog because that's the
symbol for google and
financial markets and one other
interesting thing you can do in google
sheets that you can't do
in every spreadsheet is you can include
images now this is an image that
is on the web it's my company logo and
you do
image and then you put the url for that
image in quotes
nice thing is if i make this cell bigger
that you know it increases in size as
well so
you can put an image in a cell if you
can link it from
a url i'm going to put that one back to
where it was
and then finally you have the option of
including
floating images and a number of other
things let me give you an example of
that
i'm going to come right here to insert
you can put in a chart an
image a drawing a form check boxes
comments and i'll talk about a lot of
those
let me just insert an image for right
now the one thing you need to know
when you include an image i'm just going
to get one off on my desktop
i got my datalab icon
the one thing you need to know is that
it's a floating image and so it's not
in the cell you can drag it around it's
also really big i'm going to make it
smaller
so it's not linked to this cell and
that's a little different from this web
image that we have
in the cell but it is possible to
include this
information especially if you're trying
to build up a repository or even have
sort of a branding with your
spreadsheets
it gives you many different options and
so
what you can see from all of this is
that google sheets is able to serve as a
container
for a lot of different kinds of data
each of which might arise in different
circumstances in your own work
once you have your data in google sheets
you have a lot of options for how you
format the data now this is mostly
cosmetic in terms of changing the
appearance of the data
but it's also something that can help
you organize the data that makes it much
easier to follow the argument
and bring things to your attention let
me give you
some of the really obvious things if
you've ever used a computer before
this is going to be familiar so first
off is you get to change the font
the default font in google sheets is
arial which is very
clean and it works well in a lot of
situations
on the other hand maybe you want a
different font maybe you want something
like
sorts mill gowdy that's one that i like
and you come up here and you click on
fonts and you go to source meal guide
now you may not have that because it's
not installed by default
if it's not you just go to more fonts
that takes you to a web page and you can
add a huge number of fonts
don't add all of them because then it
gets confusing but find something that
you need works for your purposes
and you can add it in here and it
becomes available
and it becomes available to anybody who
uses your document
another option is something like
consolis if you're using
code a fixed width font
is pretty common you can change the font
size so you can make it smaller it's ten
point by default
eight point is well i've got my screen
zoomed in super big so it's not too hard
to see
you can make a lot bigger and obviously
this is something you might want to do
if you are putting in headings or titles
now one thing to be aware of is you're
not limited to the choices that are here
so for instance i put
20 point but i only had 24 point just
come up here
select the number and type what you want
there's a 20 point font
you can also do the bold
all you got to do is do command or
control b or you can click on that
same thing with italics
just come up here you can do the other
command
and and strikethrough i don't use
strikethrough very often but it might be
important for your purposes
okay those are all quick and easy the
next one is text color
obviously if you've used a computer
before you know how to do this stuff
but color can be an important indicator
of both
importance and directing focus and that
can be
really important when you're putting
together visualizations or making a
table
that you're going to have to come back
to and you need help interpreting it or
you're sharing it with other people
so i can come down and select the color
there's red text you can also do
fill color that's an option so if i do
the fill
it puts in the cell now by the way when
you have a dark
fill like this you usually want to come
and pick
white text to go on top of it so it's
easier to tell what's going on
you can do cell borders and i do these
only lightly i try to keep it pretty
clean
to do cell borders select the cells that
you want to have borders on and then
come up to the
borders and you know you can put cells
borders on everything but that's kind of
a nightmare you don't want to do that
there are times i find however that it's
nice to have just
horizontal lines going through the data
it's relatively easy to direct
the line across the rows in a table
especially when it's printed
but i'm going to take that out for right
now you have but cell borders are an
option
row height you can snap it to fit or you
can have a consistent size now
snap to fit means something that
happened automatically here you saw how
that got bigger
i can drag it down so it's super huge or
i can bring it back up
either way you saw when i changed the
font size it automatically changed the
height
of the row so that the text would fit
similar to that you have options for
column width
you can snap to fit or do a consistent
size this
actually requires a small demonstration
so i'm going to put
three column headings here and i'm going
to make them
bold because i often find it's helpful
to have column headings in bold
and they're different sizes if you want
to snap to fit
you can just select these three columns
and then
double click here on the right one
and then it changes the width of each
column
so that it adjusts to the size of the
text
there may be situations in which you
want to do that on the other hand i find
that having
different size columns it can be a
little disturbing so you can also do a
consistent size
so for instance i can select all three
of them here and i can make
all of them the size of this last one if
i just click
this and drag it around a little and i
let go now all of them will be the same
size and that usually is easier to read
because you have this
uniform movement across the document
in addition to that and maybe this is a
solution you can do
text alignment now all the text that
i've got right here so far
is flush left you can of course come
over here and you can
center it you can also make it flush
right
but text is usually flush left and that
works best on the other hand
if you're doing a column you may want to
have
centered text for columns especially
with the columns or different sizes that
makes things a little easier
you also have the option of changing
vertical alignment but to make
that clear let me show you one other
thing and that is
text wrapping where it says overflow
wrap and clip
so let's make this a little more obvious
by making
all of these smaller narrower
okay so you see how this one that says
extra extra extra long is now
too big one of the options i have is to
come right here
and to change it so that it is wrapped
and that has it you know go to two lines
it it's not breaking very well if i put
in a
space here it should break better
because it treats it as a single word
there we go
now it's breaking better on the other
hand
maybe you want these other ones on the
bottom but maybe you want to vertically
orient them towards the top
towards the middle anyhow whatever works
best for your
purposes these are a lot of different
ways
that you can format the document again
the point here is not to
noodle away your time and just kind of
mess with it because you can but the
point of it is to
organize the document to make it clearer
you want
clarity and you want direction you want
to guide the eye
through your document to make the
comprehension
and analysis easier and formatting even
with this small range of options is
going to make that a lot easier to do in
google sheets
when you're getting ready to work with
your data you'll find that your life
becomes a lot easier if you have
tidy data now it's kind of a funny term
but it actually refers to something
specific
within the data science world i want you
to know that if you go to google and
type in tidy
data two of the first three are going to
take you directly to
the journal article in the journal of
statistical software by hadley wickham
that originally explained the idea of
tidy data
and you can also take you to a page on
the r project site that gives a lot more
information about what is meant by tidy
data
the idea is that data that is tidy is
easier to manipulate and is easier to
take from one
software package to another now
this is where spreadsheets are a little
problematic because spreadsheets
are amazingly flexible and they allow
you to do
a lot of things that might suit your
purposes when you're creating the
spreadsheet but they make
exporting or sharing with others kind of
a headache
so for instance i've got a spreadsheet
right here
that does some of the things that i hope
you don't have to deal with
first and foremost we've got a problem
here of merged
cells this is when you take a single
cell and you spread it all the way
across these other ones sort of as a
header there's a merged cell there's a
merge cell
this one is 15 cells merged together
and it's smack in the middle of
everything the problem
with these is they change the way the
spreadsheet functions so for instance if
i come here and click on
column f well you see it's selecting
this entire first
cell and then selecting all of this but
if i then hit
bold it only changes this one
and if i try to hit bold back it doesn't
do anything i have to do
undo and if i were to try to move it
i'm just going to come right here and
try to move it and
oops it just
doesn't want to work because of the
merged cells merge cells are things that
people sometimes do to get title
centered but they
make it really difficult to work in the
day so you don't want that
the other thing that you don't want is
you don't want to have mixed up labels
you don't want to have things spread
across in different tables that might
work for an individual project but again
if you're planning on sharing it with
other people or if there's the
possibility they might take the data out
of google sheets
and into some statistical application or
programming language they're going to
need something else specifically
tidy data means that each column
is the same thing as a variable
variables and columns
are identical and that rows and
observations are the same
thing and so we need to get some of this
cleaned up and so
another thing you can see by the way is
with tidy data is that all of the data
needs to be in the spreadsheet so this
is an important piece of information
potentially but it needs to be in a
column
to mark pieces also we've got a comment
kind of hiding right here
and it tells us something that maybe
this person could be coded as being
west or in east depending on how we want
to do it
this is not the sort of thing you want
to have in a comment because
if you export the data you lose all of
that information
and so let's take a few looks at how to
tidy things up to make them
easier to work with and less problematic
first one is get rid of all the merged
cells
get rid of those titles we had across
the top and then the information that
said the first 10
were surveyed in person
make a new column and put that in there
so now we have that information in the
spreadsheet it's not included somewhere
else
i decided not to make a change for the
comment because i didn't think that was
necessarily critical if it were then you
might want to have two locations
starting location and ending location
for each person
now there's a couple of other problems
one is that we have gender is just coded
in a crazy way we don't even know what
the zeros and ones are
f and m we can guess and so we need to
do a little bit of data cleaning right
now i'm going to come here to this tab
and you see i've done two things number
one is i took
the variable and i changed its name from
gender to female because when you have a
variable that you're going to
treat as dichotomous it's really easiest
if you use a zero for no a one for yes
and you
name the variable by what the one is in
this case i decided to assign female the
one it's arbitrary you can do whichever
one you want but for anybody who put
down that they were female i put a one
for anybody who put down they were male
i put a zero
similarly for the method of surveying
them
i decided that if they got surveyed
online i would give them a one and if it
were anything else like in person it
would be a zero
and so i've cleaned that up but there's
one more step that we need to do and it
has to do with this one right here
we've got information here about the
location the person is in
this is a different level of measurement
everything else is at the individual
level
this is now about a larger group that
they're in and we're repeating a lot of
information
if you've ever worked with a sql
database or a relational database you
know that you set up separate tables for
different levels of measurement you want
to do the same thing with tidy data
so you keep information about the
individual
but then if you have this information at
a different
level that's repeated you put that into
a separate
table and it's just a tiny little table
and then we only have to indicate
whether a person's
location was north east south or west
and we can get the rest of this
information
from this table and when you do those
things what you'll end up with
ultimately is two separate sheets you'll
have one sheet that contains all the
individual level information
where each column is a variable each row
is an observation
and all of the relevant information is
put into
those variables and columns and you'll
have a second sheet
that contains the variables for the
other level of measurement
now again this is mostly important if
you're going to be exporting your data
so it can be analyzed in another
program if you're working entirely
within google sheets it's never going
somewhere else
you might be okay doing whatever you
want just be aware
that the flexibility that you get with
spreadsheets
gives you a lot of room for creativity
but it can potentially create some
headaches and so
when in doubt take the tidy data
approach keep your data clean and make
it easy to work with
easy to analyze and easy to get meaning
out of
your analytical life becomes much
simpler and much
faster if you're able to collaborate
with other people and fortunately
that's one of the things that google
sheets does best
to share a document to share a
spreadsheet with somebody
all you need to do is come up to click
on the blue share button
and there's a lot of different ways you
can share with people now the most
direct is to simply put in
their email address right here is a fake
email address that i just got
data at superido.com and
you have the option of assigning
different levels of sharing
that that person actually can change the
document they can edit it
or they can simply make comments on it
but they can't change the actual text
or they can simply view it and you can
say
here is the document
and it will email that person and let
them know that they've got the document
and then they
get into it and they can start working
on it with you you
also have the option of sharing with a
link
so for instance you can say that anybody
at your organization if you have a
google business account or you can click
on more here
you can share anybody who has a link or
public on the web which is what i've
done on this one
and i've said it so that anybody who has
the link can view it
i could set it up so they could comment
or edit but view is going to work best
in this case
i hit save and then as long as people
have this very long link but you
click copy link and i'm going to open up
a new
incognito window click it like this
and now this is the way that anybody can
see it they can see the document
they can't change it it's giving me a
little blurb about updates here
here it says view only that's fine but
you can see that other people this is my
professional account with datalab this
is my personal account
and even though this person can't edit
it they can
download it as a microsoft excel file or
a csv or tsv
file and they can start working it on it
themselves
i'm going to close this one
now one of the nice things about the way
that sharing works
in google docs i'm going to just delete
this one i don't really want to share
with my
fake email address i'm going to press
cancel
and done but when you're sharing you can
see who's sharing right here that's my
personal account this is my company
account
and you're able to see where they are in
the document so for instance
i'm going to be in this cell right here
but i can tell
that the other person is surrounded in
pink same as we have up here
is in this cell and if i go to that
account
you can see i have the document open
that's where i am you can see that i'm
now sharing with
my company account and it's a good way
to see who's working on it where they
are
and to start collaborating to get your
analysis up and running
as fast as possible sharing an
individual sheet within
google sheets may accomplish your
purposes but often you're going to work
with people on more than one thing or
there's more than one
resource you need to share and in that
case rather than sharing each of them
individually
it's a lot easier in google drive to
share a folder
to do that all you need to do is come to
the folder that you want to share
and you get it selected and you can
either
come up here to get a shareable link you
can click on this to
share it or you can for instance option
click on it right here
and do share and then
you're going to add the person you want
to share with you can put in a specific
email address and then with that include
a message to them
or you can get a link that you can share
with people
you've got a lot of different choices
here i personally have it said that
anybody
on the web could actually search for
this they searchable on google and get
it
or they have a specific link lots of
other ways and you also have the option
of whether they can
view it see the contents or whether they
can organize
add and edit information within each of
these now right now i have it set to
just
view and let's see well if you're
looking at these files you know how it
works
but i'm going to copy the link and i'm
going to open up
an incognito window so i'm not logged
into this one
and i'll enter that link and go to it
and what you have here are the three
different files i've got a little icon
file
you can look at that one it's just a
little data lab icon
i've got an empty document that says
we're sharing this this is where it's
shared and i've got the spreadsheet that
i'm working on right now
and when i open this one
it gives us this little advertisement
let's just know that new things are
coming you can see who's logged into it
that's my personal account that's my
company account
and although you can only view it here
you do have the option of downloading
the file
just as you did when we were sharing
individual files
the nice thing of course is anything
that anybody puts into the folder is
automatically shared with everybody else
who has
access to it and when you're working on
a project with
more than one step in it say for
instance you have a presentation you
have a report
you have several different files that
build up to it
sharing a folder is going to be faster
more efficient and more effective way
of collaborating within google sheets
if you're going to work with data you
have to have some data and you have to
have it in google sheets now
the fundamental way to do this is to
enter the data directly into google
sheets and there's a lot of times where
that's the preferable solution if you're
going to be working with a statistical
program like spss or sas
it's so much easier to put it into a
spreadsheet there's a lot of advantages
to it one is
it's really easy to share and have
several people working
simultaneously on what you're doing here
now i want to show you if you're going
to be entering data manually
and say for instance is going to be
entering it based on paper surveys that
you have
there's a few things you want to do to
make your life a little easy
first off you want to have what's called
tidy data that's a term developed by
hadley wickham who works with the
statistical programming language r
and it means that a variable is the same
thing as a column and that a case is the
same thing as row and there's no funny
business going on
in your sheet so let's start with this
one if you're entering
paper the first thing you need to do is
have an id number so that you can find
the piece of paper in case something
gets entered wrong
now you may need to get at a pen and
write these numbers on a piece of paper
and then maybe you start putting in the
questions now i want to show you
something kind of neat that
google sheets and microsoft excel are
able to do
and what that is is propagating so
if you take a pattern that's easy to
follow
so for instance i like to type q01 where
q is for question
and then do q02 for question two
mind you i'm not doing q1 q2 because
it's going to think that means quarter
one quarter two in the year
but if i do the leading zeros especially
if there's more than
nine questions this is important i can
select those first two then i can just
drag them over
and it will propagate and fill in with
the same
pattern you can do that for however many
you have
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take this top column i'm going
to put it in bold
and maybe i will even
center the columns you don't have to and
there's a
there is a precedent for text columns
being
justified to the left and numbers being
justified to the right
you know it's up to you sometimes i just
like to do this so that the labels are
directly above the numbers it's a little
easier to see what's going on
and then i'm going to freeze the top row
by simply dragging this bar down and now
when you scroll up and down that top row
stays put
if you're going to be entering data from
pieces of paper like i said you need
id numbers and so you go like this 1 two
three and it can propagate that same
pattern so i'll drag it down a little
bit
and now we've got the numbers as long as
those match up with what's on your paper
you're good to go if several people are
entering the data then you might want to
be able to separate who has
what and the first person might start
with 101
and then 102 so the 1 the first 100
indicates the person
the second number indicates which one
they're working on
and then the next person can start with
201 and 202
it's okay that there are gaps that you
go straight from 107 to 201
you just can't have repeats that's the
important thing and this way
people can be working separately on
their own computers and they can be
entering the data
simultaneously in the same sheet and it
gets in there it's wonderful
and so the very simple method for
entering this
is to type in a number let's say you've
got a rating scale and people are
putting in a number
and then i hit tab go to the next one or
a right arrow and
nine and i can go through and enter like
this
i'm just hitting tab at each point when
i get to the end i hit return
and it takes me back to where i started
on the first line
and i can go on like this i can type in
the data however i want
if you have missing data if a person
didn't answer a question it's best to
simply leave it
blank and then if they typed in
something
you can put in 8 although i would hope
that they didn't type in something on
what's supposed to be a numerical
variable
but the idea here is you can put in
whatever you want and you enter the data
all the way through
and now you have entered your data
manually and you're prepared to do
subsequent analyses although it's
possible for you to enter all your data
manually in google sheets or another
spreadsheet and again
there may be situations where you need
to do that life is so much easier if you
can simply import the data and
dump it in there and get going now what
i want to show you is slightly different
from
importing a file into google drive the
place that stores files so for instance
you can take an excel file
drag it into google drive and it can
store in either
the native excel format or convert it to
a google sheets document
i actually want to show you how to
import something straight into a sheet
in an existing
google sheet and to do this we're simply
going to go up to file
and then come down here to import
and when you do that it's going to ask
you to import something
i'm going to go to upload
and select a file from my computer
actually let me show you what i have
here
i have three files here that are
identical except for their format
they're all called
import and they're just data files that
have an
id number a date a response id
five rating scale questions and a zip
code it's
this is made up data this is in excel as
an xlsx
spreadsheet this over here is the same
data in a csv or comma separated value
spreadsheet
and this one in the middle here is a
text document but they're still
separated by tabs and so it's identical
information in all of them
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
come back to google sheets
and i'm going to select one of these
files
i'm just going to take the import.csv
so i'm going to hit open and then it's
going to bring up a little dialog
box and ask me some questions about what
i want to do do i want to create a
totally new spreadsheet
no i don't even want to insert a new
sheet i want to replace
the current sheet so it's the sheet that
i already have the information on
put it there and if i want to tell it
what the separator is a tab comma or
whatever
but it can detect it automatically and
i'm using uh comma separated values so
it's
it's easy to deal with and then convert
text to numbers and dates
yes and i hit import
takes just a second and here it is it's
in
my new sheet and so i've got my
data all the rows and the columns are
intact if i want to make my life a
little easier
i'll freeze the top row
and maybe i will come here maybe i'll
select the whole thing
and make it all flush right except for
these two which i'll put then back to
flush left and my data set's ready to go
and now i can start analyzing so
importing directly into an existing
google sheet
very quick and easy way to get up and
running with google sheets
i have an untested theory that the
single most common container for data
sets in the entire world
is spreadsheets and of those i think the
majority are probably going to be
microsoft excel
spreadsheets so for instance if somebody
sends you a spreadsheet or if you
download a spreadsheet from online
it might be an excel format and even
though it's really easy to import excel
directly
into google drive or into google sheets
i do want to show you
you also can just resort to plainly copy
and paste so i've got a spreadsheet here
that's import and it's the same data
i've been using for some other examples
i'm going to select the entire set by
doing shift and then command or control
with space
i get the rectangle i'm going to hit
copy
and then just go back to excel sheets
and hit
paste i'm going to do control or command
v in this case
and there's my data i'm ready to go on
the other hand it may be
that you also are going to be using data
from web pages
on tables i do this occasionally
and so for instance if we go to this
next tab
i have a link here to a page in
wikipedia
on nobel laureates that has a table in
it
so let's open this page and it talks
about who's won the nobel prize which is
a wonderful thing to do
and here we have a table with a list of
everybody who's ever won a nobel prize
from 1901
down through
2017.
there we go now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to copy this i
find it works best if i start at the
bottom right
and i just click and i drag up
and i'm going to go up to 1901
just have to not go past it
almost there
and i'm going to copy the headings too
so now i let go
i've got that all selected i do command
or control c to copy it
then i'm going to go back to my
spreadsheet
i'm going to come to this cell right
here and all i do is i hit command or
control
v to paste it in now this is going to do
something
slightly weird and that is these are all
links
so i've got a million links on this
table and truthfully that may cause
problems as i'm trying to deal with the
data so
i'm actually going to ask google sheets
to not paste it as links but to paste it
as plain text i do that
by coming to this little clipboard that
pops up when you first paste something
and i say give me the values only
and now you see it just turns into
unformatted text and that's a great way
to go
i can then if i want to i can delete
this first row
i can then lock that first row i can
put it in bold
i can highlight the columns and then
just double click right here to resize
them
and now i've got a data set that i can
work with this is great
i do want to show you one tiny more
little trick about
copying and pasting in excel i'm going
to go to this
sheet called paste transpose and i'm
just going to type in a little bit of
data here
now i showed you in another video how
google sheets is able to fill in a
pattern
if you do one two three it just keeps
continuing or if you do q01 or q02
it can also do this with things like
days of the week
so i've got sunday monday here and i'm
just going to highlight those two
and i'll drag it down a little bit and
look we have now have the whole week
now what i want to show you is if you
want to switch it from being
arranged vertically in a column to being
the column headers
what you want to do is a special kind of
paste called a transpose or
transposition
so i'm going to copy this by hitting
control or command c
then i'll just come over here and i'm
going to do a control click it's
actually a finger click on my track pad
and go to paste
special and we've got a few options here
the one
i want to show is this one right here
paste transpose
and it flips it around from the rows to
the columns and if you're trying to set
up your data for analysis
this can save you a lot of stress about
trying to rearrange things manually
and so that's just one final tip on
getting data
by copy and paste into google sheets
when you're working with data one of the
truisms is that about eighty percent of
the time is spent simply getting the
data
ready and when you're working in google
sheets you got a few things that can
help you get the data ready
especially in terms of keeping notes for
yourself and communicating with others
in this video i want to show you how to
make notes which are a little different
from
comments which i'm going to show you
another time a note is something that
you put in a cell
that is an addition to that cell so for
instance let's try this
in this page i've got three different
sets of data i've got
days of the week i've got months of the
year and i've got a series of odd
numbers
there are a couple of mistakes in this
one so for instance we have june
appears twice here one possibility is to
make a note here
i can either right click on it that's a
two finger click
and i can insert a note or i can come up
to the menu here and do insert
note and what i'm going to say is
june appears twice
now when i click away from that you can
see that we've got this little box here
this little corner and if i hover over
the cell
then the note appears now the only trick
is
somebody has to actually be on the sheet
to know that that's there
i'll go to my other account where i'm
sharing this
and you can see that that note now
appears it doesn't say who did it
it's just a note that's in the cell now
some people
unfortunately try to put actual data
there stuff that you need to know to
interpret it please don't ever do that
this is something that can be there
temporarily in terms of drawing
attention to something
even though it's not very effective at
drawing but adding a little more context
to what you have
in the cell now a more effective way is
to actually make a comment which is what
i want to show you in the next video
when you're collaborating with others on
your data you want to be able to
communicate back and forth and sometimes
the best way is to put comments on
specific cells
within a spreadsheet now you can do
notes which i showed you previously
but those are just kind of passive and
they're there they don't draw attention
to themselves they're not attributed to
anybody
and they're really not as helpful as an
actual comment
let me show you how this is going to
work i'm going to highlight two errors
in this spreadsheet one is i have the
month
june twice now to insert a comment i can
do a few different things i can come up
here to insert
or i can use the keyboard shortcut which
can be a little different on
macintosh which is what i'm using and
windows computers
or you can also right click on it or
option click on it and come down to
insert comment that's what i'm going to
do right now
and then you see that it brings up who's
making the comment and this is my
personal account and then it's going to
say why
is this repeated
and then i can do command or control
enter or
to hit the comment and so that's thou
rephrase
and so that's now there now let's go to
the other account to see what it looks
like in the discussion
and here this highlights that there's a
comment there so it's
drawing attention to itself in the way
that a note didn't
and it lets me know who's asking the
question and i can then click on this
and say because
june was so good we wanted
it twice i can
click on reply and now we're both
in this thread
and then i can come down here oh look it
brings up my whole google plus profile
and if you want to bring in somebody
else you could click on this you could
say for instance
let's put data at sample.com
i don't think that's a real email
address
what do you think and this is a way of
bringing in
additional people to the conversation
inviting them
and highlighting the comment for them
now i'm not actually going to send this
because that's
not a real email address i'm going to
hit cancel to discard the comment
but the comment is there and you can ask
for information you can propose a
resolution
and when you finally come around to it
you can go like this you can say well
let's fix it let's do
july and then
we've now resolved it so we can hit
resolve
and it hides the discussion it archives
it and so
that is now done i can go to the other
account to see what's happened
and you can see that the comment
notification is gone the comment is gone
and it's fixed and so this is a really
good way of drawing attention to things
that need repairing
and then making the action i'll just
highlight that we have one other right
here
and i'll insert another comment
this should not be here
it's not odd
anyhow that's something you can do for
future reference as a way of
communicating with others
and it makes organizing the data and
getting ready for your analysis
a lot easier within google sheets when
you're collaborating with other people
sometimes it's sufficient to put notes
into the document or to have
the comment feature which invites a
discussion but that's
asynchronous it's not in real time on
the other hand there are
different times when having a real-time
conversation
is going to get you a lot further a lot
faster
in your work fortunately google sheets
makes
that kind of conversation really easy
with a built-in
chat functionality to do that you have
to have at least two people
working on the same document i can come
over here and see that i've got
it's open in my other account and then i
click on this icon which says show
chat and then i simply come down to the
chat window
type hello and it lets me know i've sent
them a message now let me go to the
other account
and it's telling me that there's a
message here now if i click on this it
just kind of goes away but if i come up
here where i've got my little
notification
dot i open up the chat and there it is
okay here i am
what's up and now i've got this
conversation going back and forth
and this allows people to work together
in a way to try to solve the issues
it works really well when people are
really far apart and maybe for instance
a live telephone conversation is not the
best idea
this chat history stays there
as long as anybody has the document
open so for instance let me go to my
other account
and i will close the document here
and then what you get over here is an
indication
that barton pulse and that's my other
account has left
if i close the document here
and then i open it right back up
i give it a moment to load
and there's actually nothing there
because the other person's not even in
there anymore so the chat history
disappears
once everybody closes the document but
while you're there it's a great way to
have this real-time conversation
about what's happening in the document
what tasks needs to be done
how to interpret and how to apply your
insights
certain skills seem so basic that they
don't really seem
worth discussing but it turns out that
knowing some of the special tricks
can make your life a lot easier this
applies to google sheets as it applies
to so many other things
and what i want to show you in terms of
basic skills is simply how to
select data and move it around now
obviously if you want to select just one
cell you get your
cursor and you click on that cell and
you can move it around by doing
the arrows here i am driving it around
with the arrows that's selecting one
cell that's
easy if you want to select a column just
come and click
on the letter above that column and
you've got the entire thing if you want
to select more than one column click
and drag across now you've got columns
and the same thing works for rows just
click on the row number
and you select the entire row you can
select several rows as well by clicking
and dragging
so that's easy if you want to select the
entire spreadsheet
come up here and click on this area
that's to the
top left and that selects everything
every single cell in the entire
spreadsheet let's come back up to here
let's say i want to select just this
first row now actually
to make this easier i'm going to
maximize my screen so you can see the
entire data set
i'm first going to go full screen on my
mac
and then i'm going to hide these
controls right here
and so now you can see i've got a data
set with an empty column right here and
i've got an
empty row right here that's going to
affect how some of this stuff works
now let me come up to here i'll just
stick the cursor right here
if i want to select an entire column i
can do it with the keyboard
by doing control and space and you see
what it does
is it selects vertically until it
thinks it has reached the end of the
data
and it thinks it's reached the end
because i've got this big empty row
right here so it ignores it
on the other hand if that row were not
empty let's say i put an x there
and i were to give this a title up here
i'll call that x also
now it's going to unite the whole data
set i'm going to come back over to here
i'll hit control and space and now you
see it selects down to the bottom
because now it sees this all as one
unified hole
even though there are gaps in it so
control
space selects the entire current column
i'll do control space right here
and if i want to expand my selection i
can do
shift and then use an arrow right arrow
or
left arrow to get more of what i want
there's a similar command for selecting
rows so let me just hit
escape oh actually i'll just click right
here
and i'll do shift space and what this
does is it selects the
entire row in the data rectangle if i
want to expand that
i can use the down arrow or i can use
the up arrow
and that is a way of selecting data
sometimes a little more precisely than
dragging through with the cursor
one other thing that you want to know
is about moving data so say for instance
i want to move
this score so it's on the other side of
category
what i do is you see how i selected it
and now when i come up here i have a
hand
if i just click and drag over
i've switched them around i'll put it
back by undoing that move
that's really easy i do the same thing
right here
i'll expand that i can click
and just drag down my data
and move it to a new position and this
can be
an important way of fixing the way that
you've entered things you can sort
things
manually with an id number but in terms
of rearranging variables the click and
drag is by far the easiest way to go
and so the ability to click on
individual cells and then expand
by doing shift and the arrows or to
select
rows and columns within the data
rectangle
by doing control and space or shift
in space are great ways to grab the data
you need
and perform the functions you want it's
a small thing
and again it doesn't always seem worth
it mentioning but it can make your life
much quicker and less error prone when
working in google sheets
one of the most important things you can
do for making sense of your data is to
first get it sorted put it in order
because a spreadsheet allows you to do
something called data browsing
and is to actually look at the data
that's in front of you again
it sounds like a fundamental thing but
it makes a really big difference
fortunately this is really easy to do in
google sheets
and you need to be aware this works a
little differently than it does
in microsoft excel because when there
are gaps
in excel sometimes things don't sort the
way you expect and you can actually
terminally mess up the data but in
google sheets it's really easy
now what i have is a small data set here
with an id number then i have a random
number then i got descending
letters and categories and so on here's
all you have to do to sort
come here to the top and this little see
watch how this little arrow shows up
you click on that and then you can sort
a to z which means ascending or z to a
which is descending you can actually
randomize it too
so now i've sorted it descending based
on this random number
if you want to sort it by more than one
category what you need to do
is to sort it by the last one
until the big one so for instance
i might want to have this category over
here i can show you how what it looks
like when it's sorted
i've got some fours and some ones by the
way what it's doing is it's sorting it
alphabetically
not in terms of meaning but
let's say i wanted to have these numbers
sorted within these categories the
scores so what i have to do is i have to
start with the last one
so i'm going to come to score and i'm
going to sort the sheet in ascending
values
and then i come next to category and i
sort it by ascending
values and now within four i've got my
one
two three three and so this way i can
have a first sort a second sort
but again you have to do it kind of in a
backwards method
but anyhow it's a very quick and easy
way to get things
under control also one of the reasons i
mentioned earlier is that it's really
important to have an
id row a column that gives an id number
is because it makes it possible to get
back your original order i'm just going
to sort this ascending
and i'm right back to where i was to
begin with
sometimes you only need to deal with
some of your data you don't need to see
everybody but you need to see cases that
meet specific
criteria google sheets allows you to do
this very easily with
filtering what you do is when you have
your data in front of you is you come
over and you click on this icon over
here which is the filter
and when you click that it selects the
data table
it puts the column headers and the row
headers in green
and you get these little filter icons
now you can do a couple of different
things with these you can select
text you can select scores you can
create formulas
i'll show you a two-step selection
for the filter so we can find cases that
meet particular criteria
so for instance let me come over here to
category
let's say i only want to see
category one and three i can deselect
these other two
or you can do it the other way you can
clear them all and then select just the
ones that you want either one works
so one and three and i click that and
you see it
the other ones are filtered out now and
then if i want to do
another layer on top of that for
instance i can come here to score
and i can say i only want to see cases
whose score is above
a certain value now i could select that
manually because we only have a few
choices here
but i can also come up to filter by
condition and i've got a lot of
different choices here with text and
date
and values and i'm going to say greater
than not greater than or equal to but
greater than
and i'm going to put in a 3
and when i click that the other cases
are filtered out and so now
whereas i originally had 19 lines of
data i'm
now down to a much smaller number now
it's kind of hard to tell because
it's hiding the row numbers of the cases
that were filtered out
but now i only have the six cases that
meet my two criteria of being in either
category one or three
and having a score greater than three
and so
this allows me to find particular cases
say for instance
people who have made over a certain
number of purchases or
open requests or people who've been
involved an unusually high amount with
your organization this allows you to
find those particular cases
and give them the attention that they
deserve
when you're trying to sort through your
data and filter out cases that need
special attention
you have the option of either doing what
i call ad hoc filters
which are the ones you get when you
simply click on the filter icon
and it brings up a menu like this but
you also have the option of doing what
are called filter views
which stay with the data and you can
have multiple filter views
let me show you how these are a little
different i'm going to click on
new filter view you have to click on the
arrow to get those
and then you see the window looks a
little different we've got this black
bar here
and the column headers and row headers
are in black
but let's do a filter view now what i'm
going to do here is let's say
let's get the first 10 cases i'm going
to come over here
click on this filter for id and then i'm
going to say
filter by condition where the
value is less than or equal to
10. okay when i get that i hit okay
and there we have it and see by the way
that the rows now jump from 11 to 20.
but what's interesting is i can save
this filter i come up here to where it
says
name it says filter one i just highlight
that
and i replace that with let's call it
the
first 10 cases
and so now that's a saved filter and if
i come
over to here and click on this little
side arrow
you can see it's saved right there now
let's go to none
and so it undoes that one and let's
create another filter view i'm going to
come and click on this
right arrow again say new filter view
and let's replicate
a filter i did with the other example on
regular filtering
let's come to category and select
just the one and three
so there's that one and then let's
select scores
that are greater than three
so greater than three
all right and now i've got those cases
and i can come over here and name that
one as
category 1 and 3
score greater than 3.
and so that is saved as a filter 2. so
when i come back here
i have both of those available to me and
the ability to turn it all off so if i
want to go see
just the first 10 cases i click like
this i get those
if i want my compound selection i click
like this
and it's different and if i want to have
the entire data set i simply click
none and all of these are useful i use
it all the time when i have to find
cases that have not yet been resolved
and allows me to see the open cases
and i just select down to those and i'm
able to focus on them exclusively
so it's a wonderful way to save the view
into your data and also to be able to
share it with others
and so that again allows you to sort
through your data focus on the
particular cases that are most important
and get your analysis done you may get
to a point in your analyses where you
don't want to work
with just specific collaborators but you
actually want to get out to
everybody google sheets allows you to
publish your both your spreadsheet and
your results to the entire
world wide web this is different from
sharing via link where people can
actually log in and potentially
make changes to your folder this is
actually where you can post it as a web
page or as a downloadable excel file or
a pdf
and while it makes the most sense to do
this with
individual graphics which you can embed
in a web page
i want to show you how this works in
general what you need to do is come up
to
file and then come down to publish to
the web
when you click on that you get a few
different choices you can publish the
entire document
or you can publish one of the tabs out
of it
i'll do the entire document for right
now but you may have more specific needs
and also you can publish it as a web
page in which case it'll
show up as an html web page or you can
do any of these other formats in which
case it will
simply initiate an automatic download
of the file so you don't see anything
there just go straight to your download
folder
let me show you what this looks like i'm
going to publish the entire thing
i'm going to hit publish it says do i
want to publish it
yes because you don't want to do this
stuff by accident
and now i've got this big long web
address i'm going to copy that and
go to a private
browser i'm going to open it up and now
you can see now it's not the most
attractive or well formatted but that's
because it's a web page and not the
actual spreadsheet
because i publish the entire spreadsheet
i have all of these
different tabs that are available as
hyperlink selections and so this is one
way
of sharing things now again this works
better if it's graphics that you're
sharing especially if they're
interactive graphics
i'll have an example of those later but
this is one way to get things out and
about
the other option by the way aside from
linking is to embed
the information into a website like a
wordpress site or squarespace or
your own website and then you can
include the data there
so that it's already hosted in house for
people they don't have to go to the link
directly but it's right there in front
of them
and any of those methods will allow you
to get
your data out and your message out to as
wide an audience as possible the last
thing i want to say about
sharing files and sharing your work is
of course that sometimes things go wrong
sometimes you put stuff in you
accidentally delete something or
formulas get mixed up at some way long
and
there are problems and you may want to
be able to back up the work that you did
fortunately this is really really simple
in google sheets because it has a
built-in
version history to get to this all you
need to do is come to
file and down to version history
now one of the interesting things is
that you have an option of
naming the current version you can say
draft one draft two
or clients review or whatever but let's
come here and
see the version history
when i click on that it's going to show
me all the different
changes that have been made now these
ones i mean if you click open on them
you're going to see a lot more things
and two things you have the option of
saying show me only the named version so
i have draft one and the final version
which are my
named ones and then you also have the
option saying
show the changes so if i unclick that it
simply shows you the plain document if
you click show changes it lets you know
that all of this got added and it got
added by
this person in this color the teal
barton pulse and founder
or if we back up a little more you can
see draft one and you can see for
instance that there is
information that got added
i think here are notes
you see the number of tabs changes and
that this is all new for this one
and so this is an option to hit
restore this version go back in time to
the one you had
before things got out of hand
you can recover from any mistake in
google sheets you can also
create these different versions that
allow you to have a sort of version
control so you don't have to be a fancy
person using
github or subversion or something like
that you can use the built-in
version history in google sheets to keep
track of your work
to recover from eris and see who's
contributed what
it's a great way of getting
accountability and getting
recoverability
the first graph i want to show you isn't
even technically
a google sheets graph it's a hack it
uses a function called repeat
to make a bar chart and it puts it in a
cell which
actually is really convenient and makes
a lot of other things possible
let me show you how this works what i
have here is some made-up data of the
number of social media followers a
person might have
on several different platforms facebook
twitter and so on
and i've counted the number of people
now you can also do this if you have
means averages and you put the number in
there
but let's just see how we do this i'm
going to make a column called chart
and then i'm going to type in equals
because i'm using a function
and rept which stands for repeat
now when you use the repeat function the
first thing it wants to know is what is
it going to repeat what's it going to
put in many times and you have to put it
in quotes i'm going to do the quote
and then the vertical pipe that's on the
us keyboard is above the return key
and then you tell it how many times you
want it
and that's where i refer over to this
cell
and you can see it's giving you a
preview of it right there i'm going to
close the
formula with the closing parenthesis hit
return
and now i've got 50 pipes
i'll adjust that that show an indication
of how many
people you have following you on
facebook what's neat about this is
because it's a formula i can just
drag this down like this and now i've
got it for each one of my cells and so
it's really easy to see that we've got
about twice as many people here as we
have here
as and that's about twice as many as we
have here
it's also really flexible if you want to
draw attention to one particular
category say for instance you're
interested in instagram
you can just highlight that row and for
instance you can change its color
and now you've got a bar that matches
the color you put things in so this is a
way
to make it easy to find what you're
looking for focus especially if you have
a lot of different categories you're
looking at
plus this is a flexible procedure let me
just copy this and paste it down here
now what we're getting is five more
pipes but you can put anything
other than pipes so for instance i got a
little emoji here a smiley face with
eyes i'm going to copy that i'm going to
come back over to this
and instead of the pipe i'm going to do
smileys
and so now you got a graphic you can use
any emoji you want positive negative
funny ones but it lets you get a very
quick
visualization and it's a great way to
start looking at your data
the single most useful chart that you
can make is a bar chart for
showing a quantity by category either
the number of people
in a group or an average for that group
and this is really easy to do in google
sheets
here i have a table that shows the
frequencies for a number of social media
followers in
each platform and all i have to do is
select one of these cells i got it up
here in the top and i come over
to insert chart
and google sheets are smart enough to
know that i want a bar chart by default
now you can see here if i click on
suggested it gives me a few choices but
this is a bar chart
really quick and easy there's a few
things i would want to do to modify this
first i'm actually going to move it over
a little bit so it's not overlapping
with my data
instead of saying count versus social
media followers i'm going to change the
title
i just clicked on that and i'm going to
put my
platform i'm going to get rid of this
legend here because it doesn't tell me
anything
useful so i click on that double click
and then i put none
i'm going to change this word over here
from count
to followers
and then i don't think i need this here
on the bottom so i'm just going to
select that and then delete it
and then finally i think i'm going to
change the color of the bar so i'm going
to double click on the bars
pick a different color i personally like
this red
and so there's an excellent bar chart
now i will mention
one funny thing technically this isn't a
bar chart it's a column chart because
it's vertical
a bar chart goes sideways and so let's
take a quick look at how we can
make it a bar chart i'm going to copy
this chart
and then paste it and then i'll drag
this down a little
so i can put it underneath i'll scroll
up now
and all i need to do is double click on
this chart
and then come over and tell it i no
longer want a column chart i want
a bar chart now i'm going to have to
clean things up it went back to the
default
title so i'm going to change that again
to by
platform
and i'm going to delete this again
and i need to clean this up again
but the reason this is a good chart the
sideways
bar chart is because if you have long
labels now the words facebook twitter
and instagram are not long
but if they were longer then this makes
it easier to read them because you don't
have to turn your head sideways or
something
and it puts it in the same orientation
as the bar itself
so it's easier to follow through with it
in a logical
manner anyhow this is the simplest chart
you can make a bar chart a column chart
and
truthfully 90 of the time it's going to
give you all the information you need
to make the conclusions based on your
data
a recent development in google sheets is
a way that makes it even easier to
create
bar charts now in another video i showed
you how to create bar charts using a
table where you summarize
the number of cases you have in each
category but google sheets is also able
to do this with raw data
so here i just have a list of a whole
bunch of followers we have pinterest
facebook facebook so on and so forth we
can scroll down you can see they're all
kind of jumbled in there but we don't
even have to count them
all i need to do is come over to this
insert chart
click on that and it creates a bar chart
it counts it all by itself now i'm going
to
still do a couple of things here to
clean this one up
i'm going to change the title here
so that it says social media followers
by platform i'm going to get rid of this
legend because it's not helpful and
takes up a lot of space
i'm going to change this over here to
say just say
followers on the vertical axis and on
the horizontal axis i don't need that
title at all so i'm going to
just delete that and there you have it
you got a bar chart quick and easy
now the only major qualification on this
one
is that you see the bars are out of
order what they are is they're in the
order that each category first
appears in the data so you can see the
very first one is pinterest the second
one is facebook then we scroll down a
little bit we get twitter
and you can't modify that and so that's
one small problem but it still makes it
really easy to see that
most of the followers are from facebook
the least are from medium
and it lets you start getting insights
in your data without even having to do
the data prep of putting it in the table
first
if you want to look at the relationship
between two different variables
or two different outcomes and how they
affect your results
a grouped bar chart can be a really good
way to do this
so here i have the same social media
followers data
i have had before but now i've labeled
the data we've had previously as
subscribers and i've added a new column
for visitors you might be able to tell
these apart and get separate reports in
your analytics software
but let's see how we can show each of
these and what's interesting
is this is where google sheets gives us
a few important alternatives
i'm just going to select this first cell
here come over to
insert chart and once again it's nice
that google sheets is smart enough to
select the entire table of data and it
gives it a good title
and what we have here is a side-by-side
chart now i'm going to make just a few
changes here
i'm going to put again here by
platform and although
in other examples i've gotten rid of the
legend the legend is important in this
one because you can see that blue means
subscribers and red means visitors
on the other hand with a vertical column
chart like this where things are side by
side having the
legend off to the right isn't really
helpful because you've got to go back
and forth to look so i'm going to click
on this
and instead of having it on the right
i'm going to put it on the bottom
and now you can see that we have the
blue on the left
the red on the right and it's the same
orientation as our other data
i'm going to get rid of this because
it's just taking up space and we don't
need that
and now it's a little bit closer and
then i am going to add
one other thing we don't have an
vertical axis here i'm going to
add that one vertical axis title
and i'll put followers
okay and so this is a basic
side-by-side chart and what you can get
from this is that we've got a lot
of subscribers in facebook we've got
more there than any other platform
and we've got a lot of visitors on
facebook but also instagram and a ton
on pinterest by the way this is totally
made up data
but you see a different pattern on
linkedin where it's a small number but
we have more subscribers and visitors
again this is made up
your situation may be completely
different but i want to show you
two other ways of arranging a grouped
bar
chart that gives you different kinds of
insight
maybe you're not so concerned about
whether a person's a
visitor or subscriber but whether they
simply come to your site and follow you
at all in that case you can rearrange
the chart by
stacking the blue and the red here's how
you would do it i'm going to copy this
chart
and paste it here i'm going to scroll
get this
drag it down a little bit and then get
it
so this is a simple copy of what we had
before
but i'm going to double click on it and
this time i'm going to come to this
option under data that says stacking
right now it says none because things
are right next to each other they're not
stacked at all but if i do
standard stacking now it puts the one
on top of the other and you can still
see that you know we've got
more subscribers in facebook than
anything else we've got a lot of
visitors on pinterest
but overall you can see we're getting
the most visits from pist
the second most from facebook the third
most from instagram
and so you can combine them to get a
total this can be really really helpful
and in this case you might actually want
to put
the legend back on the right because you
want to have things arranged top and
bottom
and so now we have visitors on top
subscribers and that might be a better
way to do it
now there's one other option and
the deal is it's hard to compare
proportions with this one you're able to
look at absolute frequencies
but maybe you want to look at
percentages of visitors who are
subscribers
versus regular visitors and so we have
one more option with a grouped bar chart
i'm going to
copy this chart
paste it in and i will bring it down
here
we'll scroll up i'm actually going to
make a couple of changes on this one the
first thing i'm going to do
bring it up just a little more is i'm
actually going to change the chart type
now right now it's a stacked column
chart but
again sometimes a bar chart which is the
horizontal left to right chart
might be a better choice
what i'm going to do here first is i'm
going to change
the kind of stacking instead of standard
i'm going to go to what's called 100
where it gives us not the frequencies of
the accounts but the proportions of
people
and now for instance you see that
linkedin becomes huge in terms of the
number of subscribers
if we go back to standard for a second
you can see that there's only a small
number of people
visiting from linkedin in my artificial
data
but the proportion
who are subscribers is huge compared to
the others and the
proportion of subscribers is very small
in my pinterest data just 10.2 percent
now i want to show you one other thing
you can do i'm going to
delete this one we don't need that at
all
and i'm going to put a horizontal axis
title to say
proportions of followers
because remember 0.25 means 25
0.5 means 50 and so on i'm
probably going to put the legend back on
the bottom
and then i'm just going to change the
colors because i can i'm going to come
in here and click on the red and i'm
going to change it to
say for instance a gray here
that's a little prettier to look at but
these are three variations on group bar
charts they're showing you
both the platformer person's on and
they're showing you whether they're a
subscriber or visitor
and they give you different insights one
allows you to look at the absolute
frequencies next to each other the
second one lets you look at the totals
and the third one lets you look at the
proportions
all of them are valid all of them give
different perspectives on your data
and any of them can be used to help you
plan what your next step should be in
your social media campaign
most people when they think of
spreadsheets they think of microsoft
excel
and google sheets is very similar to
excel a lot of the functions carry
straight over
but there are some differences part of
it's because it's actually a web sheet
that gives it a lot more
functionality in that respect but some
things don't operate quite the way you
would think
if you want to make a bar chart and make
one of the bars a different color
in excel all you got to do is click on
that bar and manually change its color
but in google sheets you have to do it
differently
say for instance i would have my data
here on social media followers and i
want to draw attention to instagram
well it turns out that the way to make
instagrams bar a different color than
the others is to actually make a grouped
bar chart what i'm going to do is i'm
going to create a
second column here i'll call it
highlight
and then i'm going to take instagram's
value and i'm going to move it over
so this is kind of a funny data because
no platform has values in both of these
columns they're in either one or the
other
but watch how this works i come to
social media followers
and i click insert chart and it makes by
default a grouped bar chart but it's a
really funny looking one because
everything's half width it's expecting
information from each of the columns but
if we come over here to
stacking and we change it to standard
then we suddenly have what we want
there's a couple of things i want to
change however that i think are
important number one is i want to get
rid of
this legend it's actually creates
confusion so we get rid of that
and we need a real title social
media followers by
platform and then i can delete this one
here on the bottom
by just deleting this text over here
and now we've got a simple bar chart
column chart actually
where we're able to draw attention to
one particular category
instagram by putting its value in a
different column and making a stacked
bar chart
it's a funny way to have to go about it
but it still lets you get
to the same goal of making a clear
visualization
and drawing attention to the important
values
another way of showing the number of
cases or observations in a category in
addition to bar charts
is with pie charts now i have to mention
there's a lot of people in the data
visualization world
who get very upset at the mere mention
of pie charts
but i want to point out there's a few
reasons in which pie charts are actually
a good choice
number one is if you're required by your
work to use them if you have a template
and they use pie charts
that's what you got to use second there
actually is some evidence to say that
certain groups of people find in pie
charts easier to read
than bar charts especially if you're
talking about allotment of time during
the day
third there are some times where a pie
chart actually can be easy to read
especially if you're only trying to show
one number a percentage but let me give
you a few examples here
i'm going to take the social media
followers data and i'm going to come
over and click
on the insert chart now by default
google sheets makes a good choice and
creates a bar chart
but we're going to make things a little
different now you'll
notice by the way that i changed the
order of things i put
instagram first that's because in other
examples i wanted to draw attention to
instagram
but if you're going to have one
particular category you want to focus on
in a pie chart it should
be the first one that means it'll start
at 12 o'clock
and it'll be the one that leads off the
impressions
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
come back here to chart type
and you can see we have right here a
suggested type
is a pie chart and this is the default
pie chart or the
beach ball or the pinwheel and you know
it's not horrible how it is i'm going to
change a few things i'm going to change
this title here
social media
followers by platform
and then i'm going to make one other
thing
where i put some information here in the
slices now the way i do that is by
coming over to pie chart
and i'm going to say slice label each of
these
segments is a slice i'm going to say
label
now i realize that what i just put in
here
is redundant because it says instagram
here and it says instagram here too and
unfortunately i can't control
what is displayed right here that's the
hard part
but i'm going to show you a couple of
things we can do about
that on the other hand i want to point
out these labels first off
because the medium slice is small the
word medium didn't show up and twitter
is shown in a different color which
under certain circumstances might be a
good idea but
it's a little weird in this one i'm
going to fix that
by coming here again to pie chart
and i'm going to make the labels a
little smaller i think if i go to
14 nope i got to go smaller still
to 12 point there then they're all
inside and i can also
change their color i'm just going to
make them all white
and so now it's a little more uniform
and it's a little easier to read and
instagram you can see the one i want to
talk about is right here at the very
beginning
that's nice but i want to show you an
easier way
to draw attention to what you want and
to avoid some of the
optic you know overwhelm
of a pie chart so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to
copy this chart
i'm going to do copy paste it and i'll
make a copy i'll
drag it down here
and what i'm going to do them is several
things but the
single most important one is i'm going
to change the chart type
now there are two ways to do this if we
were to come back to data
here and you see chart type says pie
chart now let me show you if we scroll
down here you can see there are three
variations on the pie chart there's the
standard pie chart
there's a donut chart and that's
actually the one we're going to use
but i'm going to show you there's
another way to get to that and then
there's the
3d pie chart which is lean back which
actually is a horrible thing for data
visualization because it actually
distorts the data
it's harder to read just don't ever
use that but i can get a donut chart
by clicking this one or i can come back
to customize
and you may have noticed this option
earlier the donut hole
right now to zero percent i can make it
25 so it's a little doughnut hole i can
make it
bigger 50 i can make it bigger still you
can enter in any number you want
50 seems to work well for a lot of
purposes especially if you still want
labels in there now i'm going to make a
few
other choices i'm going to come back up
here to chart style
and i'm going to do kind of a fun one
here which is maximize
and that gets rid of the title and it
makes the chart as big as it can be
then i'm going to come down to legend
that's these things right here facebook
31.3 percent
instagram 16.3 i'm just going to get rid
of that
so now i just have this colorful
donut i'm going to change the colors of
each of these because i want to draw
attention to
instagram so i'm going to click on that
and you have to change each of these
manually but i can do it pretty quickly
i'm going to make all the ones that i
don't want to emphasize
a uniform gray there's a gray that's
right above the bright green seems to
work well
and so all of them get to be that gray
except for the instagram which i want to
emphasize
now there's one major problem here and
that is you can't tell where the slice
is start or stop it's
really hard to tell so i'm going to
click back on these
and i'm going to come back up to pie
chart and do a border color
and the border color i'm going to use is
going to be a lighter shade of gray
say maybe this one right here it's not
much but it's a
makes it possible to tell apart the
slices
and so this is a good step it's a way to
see that
instagram is about 1 6 in fact it's 16.3
percent
and you can see how it compares to the
others now there's one thing that i
personally like to do in addition to
this and i usually do this in
presentation software so if i'm doing
this in google slides
i'll add a little piece in there but it
can be done
here in google sheets as well i'm going
to add a number
that says how big this is as a
percentage
now if we come back up here you'll see
that it's 16.3 percent
that's good what i'm going to do is i'm
going to
bring this up and i'm going to insert
a drawing
this is kind of a funny way to do it but
it works you know it's a little bit of a
hack
i'm going to insert a text box i'm going
to type in the number
percent and then i'm going to make it a
pretty font i'll use garamond
and then i'm going to make it much
larger
i'm going to bring it up to 48 point
i can make that box a little smaller
i hit save and close and now it's over
here floating on the side but i can just
click on that
drag it over and sort of eyeball to
position it in here
and now what you have is you've got a
number in the donut hole that says
exactly how big
the one highlighted piece is and it
makes it really easy to read and so this
is a situation where i actually think
that
pie charts or really their relative the
donut chart
can make it easier to present a kind of
information
and can give better clarity to your
presentation
when you have a quantitative or measured
variable
like the price of an order or the amount
of time somebody spent on your website
or the number of kids in a family you
want to make
a histogram as a way of looking at the
overall shape of the distribution
it helps you see if there's any spikes
in particular places helps to see if
there's
gaps and outliers so let's take a look
at some artificial data
i have here on hypothetical orders or
totals from particular clients and we've
got a
bunch of rows of data here 113
but let's just come over and click on
insert chart
one of the things is google sheets again
is smart and it's able to figure out
that a histogram would be most
appropriate for this
there's a few things that we need to
change however i need to click on this
and get rid of the legend because it's
just silly and taking up space
and what you can see is that most of the
orders are down here low
it's drawing a box that goes from
zero dollars to one thousand six hundred
and fifty dollars next one to
three thousand three hundred dollars by
the way the
width of these boxes the fact that it
goes to sixteen fifty than thirty three
hundred
that's called the bucket width or bin
width and it's arbitrary you can make it
as small as you want as big as you want
what google sheets is doing is it's
using
a rule of thumb that says you know
usually somewhere around 7
9 11 bars is best and so it's dividing
the data up to do that
and you can see we've got one case
way up here we've got this big gap here
in the middle this is a skewed
distribution which is actually what you
expect anytime you're dealing with
something like
money and we've got this one big outlier
now when you have an outlier like this
the first thing you want to do is see
is that data correct and if it is
correct
then you get to decide what you want to
include it in
it may be for instance that because it's
so unusual it represents a different
category you don't want to include it
with the others
but let me show you a couple of things
you can do to help clean up a histogram
to help decide what's going on with your
data i'm going to double click on this
and well since it brought me to this one
i'm just going to change the color
because i
prefer that color but let me come back
up to
histogram you can change the bucket size
now
it's doing buckets at 1 650 each which i
think
is silly so i'm going to manually change
them to 1
000 each and while it does
introduce a lot more empty space here
it's easier to read them i'm going to
change
these values here and not have them
slanted slanted is really hard to read
i'm just going to make them straight up
vertical
at least it's easier to tell what's
going on there
and so this is one way of looking we
still have this big outlier we've got
this huge gap but it lets us know where
most of our cases are now google sheets
does give you one option for dealing
with outliers
of course you could just exclude it from
the data say this is not representative
of the group that we want to deal with
or you could use a different kind of
analysis
but there is one option so i'm going to
double click on this
come to the histogram and it's this one
right here it's
outlier percentile and what this does is
it takes the
highest certain percent of cases and it
brings them
down and puts them in the next lowest
bar so
watch what happens when i do this right
now we've got this
one case up here we've got this huge gap
and then the next highest is at 5000.
so if i click this one percent boom
it brings it way down now what it's also
done unfortunately is it's changed the
way it draws the bins and labels
and it gives them these really weird
arbitrary cutoff points and
unfortunately there's really not much
you can do about that you know
you can try going down to horizontal
axis and manually setting the values to
zero but
once you've done the binning thing it
doesn't have any effect
but it still lets you see the pictures
that yeah most of our cases are down
here then we got this
we've got this little gap here then we
got a couple of cases that are higher
you could do a higher percentage if you
wanted you could do for instance five
percent and you see it changes a little
bit more
but you're never going to get rid of
these weird bins down here so
the only way to get rid of those by the
way is to just back up and do
the undo and undo and undo
and now you're back to where you were
originally but
the important thing here is that google
sheets is able to draw
a histogram by default you're able to
see that most of your
order totals are in the 1000 or 2000
range
and then you got this really huge gap
with this one extremely high total up
here more than three times as high as
anybody else
but this is the purpose of a histogram
to help you find these
generalities where most of the orders
are and the outliers
exceptions and so this gives you a good
start on trying to make sense of your
orders and what you want to do
next in your business one of the most
important things you can look at in an
organization is
change over time that might be the
number of customers you have the number
of people you reach
the amount of money you bring in there's
a lot of different things
and one of the best ways of looking at
that is with a
line graph where you have time across
the bottom
and the quantity that you're looking at
measured vertically now i'm going to
show you how to do
both a single line graph and a multiple
line graph
what i have here is some made-up data of
revenue
from several different sources for a
non-profit organization
so we have donations we have events that
they run
for say for instance ticket sales we
have grants that they receive
from private or government organizations
and the total amount of revenue
for each month and i've only got it for
about a year and a half here
but this is enough to show us how these
kinds of graphs work and the value you
can get out of them
i'm going to start by doing just
donations although i do have to
select month also because that's what
goes across the bottom so i'm selecting
these two columns
and i come over and i hit insert chart
and it does a line graph by default and
so you can see that things are
kind of flat here at the beginning then
there's a big jump
and by the way if you just hover over it
can tell you what the actual values are
at each point
but there's a few things that would be
important to modify in this
graph first off is i'm going to put
not donations versus month that makes it
sound like there's an opposition but
donations by month and then we don't
need
this legend over here because there's
only one line doesn't tell us anything
useful
so i'm going to hit none
and then i'm going to make a couple of
other modifications to this chart one is
i
i don't like you know the jagged line so
i'm going to change
its color i'm going to change its
thickness i find a thicker line is often
easier to deal with the four point seems
to work well
and then i'm going to put points on to
indicate the actual
values the observations so you see now
we have a point at each place
that's helpful another thing you can do
is i'm going to scroll back up to the
top here to chart style
is i have an option to smooth the
line because right now it goes straight
bend straight bend and it's
i think that the jagged parts draw too
much attention to themselves so by
smoothing it out
we make it curved and it's a little
easier to see the pattern over time
now just as a note there is a separate
smooth line chart as a type so you can
choose that if you want
but since i was just using the automatic
insert chart
customizing it seemed like a good way to
go the next thing i want to fix
is this over here we've got five
thousand ten thousand fifteen thousand
and it's easy to read but the thousands
parts
takes up more space than i want so i'm
gonna click on that
and i'm gonna come here to the vertical
axis to the scale factor
and when i hit 1000 it divides all of
these numbers by one thousand but i need
to make sure that we don't think
we're receiving just ten dollars in
donations
so i'm gonna modify this vertical axis
title
and then in parenthesis i'll put
thousands and then there's one more
thing i want to do here
and that is right down at the bottom
it's giving me
some of the months and you know maybe
that's okay
but personally i'd like to see all of
them and so all i have to do is click on
that and come to this one under
horizontal access and say treat
labels as text and when i do that it
shows
all of them on the other hand it also
slants them which is hard to read so i'm
going to change that to 90 degrees
and then i don't think we need this
title here anymore for the axis because
it's explanatory what it is
and so there is a very clear
line chart that shows the variations in
donations
by month from october of 2016 through
february of 2018.
it's really easy to see the changes you
want to see
what happened between here and here to
cause this big spike
what happened to get it all the way up
to this maximum and why did it fall so
quickly
and so those are some of the issues that
you're going to want to look at
but fortunately this is what the purpose
of this
visualization is is to bring these
things to your attention so you can
investigate it
now i showed you at the beginning
there's more than one source of revenue
for this organization
there's not just donations there's also
events there's grants and there's a
total
we can get all of those into one chart
i'll show you how that works what i'm
going to do is i'm going to make a copy
of this chart
so now i'm going to take this new chart
i'm going to drag it down
and move things up but not all the way i
want to keep a little bit of the data
showing over here because i need to
change the data that i'm using so i'm
going to click on this
and do edit chart then i'm going to hit
data range
now when i do that i can simply come
over to the data and if i do shift
command
space on a macro shift control space on
a pc
it selects the entire block of data i
hit that and
voila there's all my data now i'm going
to come up
and i'm going to make some changes to
this i'm going to come over here and i'm
going to
select all series and i'm going to do
all of them 4 pixels thick and all of
them were 7
pixel dots now because i changed
this red one manually that means this
darker orange one sort of conflicts and
so i need to change its
color so i'm going to come here to the
darker orange one which is events
and i'm going to change it to a blue
great so now we can tell them apart a
little better
now there's a couple of other things i
need to do because i change the nature
of the data
number one is i need to change the title
here because this is no longer just
donations i need to put
revenue by
source by month and then here on the
side
i need to change donations to
revenue there we go and there's one
other thing
because i have several different lines
you need to know which is which
and so i need to put the legend back in
so i'm going to put legend and then i'm
going to put it on the
well let's see how it looks on the right
there's on the right
and there is on the bottom
i actually think that maybe in this case
the one on the bottom looks a little bit
better because we get a little more
linearity
in the chart that we have going across
in any case this is a way of looking at
the change
over time of several different values
and it lets you see
how the multiple sources contribute to a
total
and gives you a better picture in this
case the financial health of your
organization
if you want to show changes over time
you do have the option of doing the
basic line chart which i've showed
elsewhere
but google sheets also gives you a
specialized timeline which is
designed for things that have months or
years on the bottom
and a change in a quantity often
financial over time
i'm going to use the same data here and
i'm going to show you how to make this
specialized timeline
i'll start with just the first two
columns month and donations
and when i click on the insert chart
it's going to give us the default
timeline which we've had before but i'm
going to come here to chart type
and i'm going to click that and go way
down to the bottom
where we have the timeline chart and
when i click on that
it's a different kind of thing it
actually gives you some
interactive functionality now i'm going
to do a couple of things first
just to clean it up and come here to
customize
and i'm going to change the line
thickness from one to four so the line's
thicker
and i'm going to give it fill opacity
just 10 percent which fills in the area
beneath it
and it makes it a little easier to see
what's going on
there's one other important thing you'll
see that these values here go from 5000
to ten thousand to fifteen thousand
but they don't start at zero and in my
mind they should always start at zero so
i'm gonna
click on this box expand range to show
zero
and now we're set that's as many options
as i have for this
but what i want to show you is that when
you come over it you see
as i go over a particular value
it will highlight that value
and give us the date and the amount you
can control it
two different ways number one is you can
come down here and you can drag this
box to set your own
time range that's you know that's the
whole point of having the timeline
or you can use these zoom buttons you
can say go back to the max
show me the last year show me the last
six months
if you've ever worked with financial
data on the web you often have
these same options
now this is a simple timeline with just
one
variable being displayed we can do more
than that in fact i'm going to come back
here and i'm going to copy this chart
and then let me drag that new copied
chart down
not overlapping
and what i'm going to do in this chart
is i'm going to change
the data that it uses and i'm going to
give it
all of the data i'm going to come back
up here just click in here and do the
shift
controller command and space bar that
selects the data
and now i've got all of it there and
there's really nothing else i need to do
because it
maintains all the same options that i
already set
but you know we can still do the
interactive thing we can
click right here we can come back a
little bit and as i come in
you see how it says donations events
grant and total up here at the top
as i come into the chart it'll give us
the actual values of each of those
as we scroll through and so that is a
great way to explore the data and to see
what's happening there as well
and so the timeline chart well it has
fewer options overall
gives you some very specific functions
that are hard to assemble on your own
but give you the ability to explore your
data in more detail
changes in spreadsheet graphics may come
slowly but they
do come and one of the more interesting
developments
in data visualization in spreadsheets
especially in google sheets
is something called a sparkline now this
is a concept that derives from work by
edward tufte really father of modern
data visualization
but the idea here is to create a very
small graphic that fits
in line with text and in the case of
spreadsheet it means it fits
right in a cell what i'm going to show
you is how to make
these in cell visualizations for several
different kinds of data because the
sparkline
function in google sheets is pretty
flexible now
this is a formula so i type
equals and then i start typing in
sparkline and you can see it says it's
going to give me a miniature chart
within a single cell i just need to tell
it what data
so i highlight this data and then i
close the parenthesis
and then there it is i now have a
timeline chart it's really small
i'll make it bigger for right now
let's scroll down a little and so now
i've got this little timeline chart that
shows the
variation in donations over time it sets
it so that the lowest value is at the
bottom the highest values here at the
top and it just moves over one step at a
time
it doesn't indicate months it's just
going from this cell to this cell to
this cell
but here's a neat thing because it's a
formula
i can do what i do with other formulas
and i can drag it
to apply to other columns and so now
i've got this little timeline for each
one of them
this is really a marvelous thing when
you've got a bunch of different data
sources you want to look at them
really quickly also because they're in
each cell you know i can just make the
cell bigger
if i want to and now the charts are
bigger
also you have the option of changing
some of the properties of each sparkline
so for instance this one
right here it looks like it goes from
really low to really high but if you
scroll through the data
you see that it actually goes from 12
000 to 20 000
and so it's a little misleading to have
it start that low we can
change where it starts by
fixing a parameter called ymin so i'm
going to double click on this
i'm going to come right here and i'm
going to paste in
a comma and then in curly brackets
because that's how you do arguments in
google sheets for sparklines i put in
quotes ymin that's the thing i want to
change
comma and then the value i want it to
have
i enter and now you can see it's bumped
up
so that it's a little over halfway up
that's a big improvement over what we
had
you can change other things as well you
can change for instance the color and
the line thickness which i'll do with
this one
this is our total so it should appear a
little bit differently
i'm going to put in there two arguments
one i'm going to change the color and
this is a hex code it's a way of
specifying colors it's frequently used
with computers
this is the dark red that i've been
using in lots of other things
then i put a semicolon because i'm going
to include a second argument
that is line width and 2 means 2 pixels
and now i've got a total chart
which is a stands apart from the others
but also let's just see the change in
time and so this is a really
handy way to look at data and the
flexibility being able to do it in a
cell is a fabulous thing
now i'm going to come over i'm going to
put this back down for a moment to 100
i'm going to come over to this next
column this is called win loss now you
may not be doing this in your data
this originally comes from sports about
whether a team won a game or lost a game
and i'm putting in some zeros to
indicate that they didn't play or there
was a rain out or something like that
you can adapt this to other things like
for instance whether you got a new
client whether you lost a client
i don't know whatever works well for you
i'm going to come down here and i'm
going to
put in another sparkline so i'm just
going to go a sparkline
and i'm going to select the data now if
i just do this by default
it'll draw the same kind of line graph
that i have over in the others
and that might be helpful but with wind
loss data there's a special kind of
sparkling so i'm going to
open up that one and i'm going to insert
this extra information where i say chart
type is
win loss all one word here and when i do
that
it gives me this little collection of
bars on the top half and on the bottom
half let me zoom in on those
i'll go back to 200 scroll over a little
bit
come down here and so you can see that
we start with
two wins we got a couple of rain outs
and then a loss of wind a few losses
and it's a way of seeing this pattern of
a dichotomous variable
over time you can do things like you can
put different colors for the tops and
for the bottom you can put a line
through the middle you can there's a lot
of options for coloring this
but this is the default win loss chart
now i want to come and finish with
one other one i'm going to back this
down to maybe 150.
and that is the social media follower
data that i've used before
i did this with a repeat chart which
allowed me to draw just vertical bars
using a formula all the way across there
is a way to do this with sparklines but
it
takes a little bit of adaptation so let
me do
this i'll enter sparkline and then i'll
tell it the thing i'm going to
draw is this i'm going to close the
parenthesis now i'm going to get an
error message
and the reason i'm going to get an error
is because it says
you need at least two data points and i
only gave it one
but i'm doing a different kind of data
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
double click on this
and then right here i'm going to insert
that i'm doing
a bar chart so i put comma and then in
curly brackets
chart type comma bar and when i do that
it draws a bar that fills up the whole
cell that's actually kind of neat and i
can drag it down but you'll see there's
another problem here
it just automatically assumes that each
bar should go to the maximum
so right now it's not telling us
anything what i have to do is i have to
change
the maximum on each of these so that it
each one of these bars has as its
maximum the
maximum value here in our account which
is this 50. so i'm going to double click
on this one
i'm going to come right here and i'm
going to insert another argument
now what i'm putting is max is equal to
the maximum
of this range of data and i have to use
the
dollar sign two and dollar sign seven so
that it always stays
row two to row seven as i drag the
formula down now the first bar is not
going to look any different
but as i drag it down now you see that
all the other ones adjust
they show you what proportion they are
of the
maximum score of 50. and so sparklines
are a really creative and new way
of visualizing several different kinds
of data
changes over time wins and losses over
time
even simple bar charts but all done
within cells which allow you to
rearrange them in a number of ways
they've got a lot of other options you
can explore some of those
but this is a really a fun development
in data visualization in google sheets
wouldn't you like to be able to predict
the future or at least
try to guess how things are going to
happen very soon
one way to do this is with using scatter
plots and associations
between two quantitative or scaled
variables
in this example i'm looking at the
number of sales in quarter one and the
number of sales in quarter two these are
totally made up numbers
but i want to show you how to build a
scatter plot and get some predictive
value out of it now when i take these
data
and i just click on insert chart by
default it gives me the
two line charts which is definitely not
what i want i want to see how they
connect
one with another so i click here on
chart type
and one of the suggested charts is a
scatter plot
and this lets you see the connection
between
sales and quarter one and sales and
quarter two so for instance we got one
quarter here
that was really low in quarter one
it's about a ninety but super high in
quarter two so things went better
why do the others it was just kind of
uniform that quarter two seem to be
pretty consistent
now i do want to show you a couple of
ways to modify these charts that might
make it work better for your
presentations
the first of these is that i'm going to
come in
and i'm going to change just for
instance the colors
i'm going to change it to red
and then i'm going to take this option
right here and add a trendline what this
is is a straight line that goes through
the data that summarizes the
relationship between the two
and because we've got this really
unusual score over here that's
super low on x and super high on y we
end up with a
downhill pattern overall i can make that
a little thicker if i want i'll make it
to four point
and um you can change the color and the
opacity but i'm going to do one other
thing here it's going to say
show r squared now this is a little more
than i really want to do when i'm
talking about visualization because this
is getting into actual data analysis
but this is a statistical measure of the
strength of association between two
variables it goes from zero to one and
you read it like a proportion
so the fact that this one says trendline
for sales and it says
r squared equals 0.091
that tells you that nine percent of the
variance
in quarter two sales can be accounted
for by the variance in
quarter one sales it's a technical thing
but it lets you know there's an
association there but it's small
i'm going to do one other thing and then
call it quits on this i'm going to come
back to this trendline but i'm going to
go to series because what i want to do
is i want simply want to change the
title for this it gives custom label
trendline for q2 sales i'm just going to
remove that
so we just have the r squared there and
then that
is a good final chart for looking at the
association between two variables
if you're familiar with scatter blocks
and if you understand how regression
works
then this is the best way to look at the
association between
two quantitative variables you can re
repeat it for
lots of different possible associations
to find the variables they can give you
the best predictive insight into what's
happening in your organization
if you want to draw a scatter plot to
show the association between
two quantitative variables but you want
to draw attention
to one of the observations you want to
for instance change its color
again in other programs this might be
easy to do just click on the dot
change it but in google sheets as we saw
with
bar charts if you want to change a bar
you got to do it in kind of a funny way
the way it works here is again we create
a
new column for the one data point that
we want to highlight
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to have our q1 and q2 sales
and let's say that we have a new
channel a new method of making sales and
we want to highlight that one
i'm going to come down here to this 116
because i know this is an unusual score
i'm going to cut it out of there and
paste it over here and now you see we've
got this one value sitting in this
column all by itself let me highlight
all of this data
just doing the shift command or control
in the space bar
and then come over to insert chart
now what it does is it gives me these
three bar charts which is definitely not
what i want i'm going to come down to
scatter plot
and now when i move this over you can
see
that the one unusual value is here all
by
itself way up high and that accentuates
it so we can see that
something else is going on with this
particular data set
now another option i have here is to
draw a trend line
and it does the trend line for the
collection of the data you can see that
you know it's really kind of flat all
the way through
and that highlights that it's really
consistent
from q1 to q2 except for this one
special new channel
that has been massively productive in
getting us sales
in the second quarter so again it's a
little bit of a hack but if you want to
highlight the one of them
in google sheets you're going to need to
put that value into a
separate column you only need to put one
of the values for it
into a separate column and that will
allow you to put it in a different color
and draw attention to it
an important thing to remember about
google sheets is that it's made by
google and so it's not just a
software company this is a very serious
tech company with
very high end machine learning and even
artificial intelligence
and they have found ways to bring this
into google sheets and so
i thought i'd end this chapter by doing
something that kind of pulls the rug out
from under a lot of the other work i did
by showing you the
automatic graphs you can get
from a new feature in google sheets
called explore
if you look way down in the bottom right
you will see a green button here that
says explore
and it shows up in several different
programs it'll show up in docs it'll
show up in
slides but here in sheets it does
something in particular i'm going to
click on explore
you can also do the option shift x and
it brings up
this window on the right and it allows
you
to ask for instance like what's the
correlation between events and donations
these two different sources and look
it'll give you a scatter plot
it'll even give you a formula and
you can get this information a lot of
these directly from right here
you can format the document if you want
to do it in
shades of green look now it'll do it for
you that's quick and easy
but the important one is down here with
analysis it starts producing a
series of charts and some of these we've
made on our own
let's say for instance this one right
here
the idea is it makes a chart it even
gives you a little bit of interpretation
for every year donations increases by
about ten thousand three hundred dollars
that's fabulous now you can also click
on this button if you want to see it
larger
and it fills it up right there hit
escape and go back
or you can even add it to make it a part
of your spreadsheet i'll just click this
plus button
and now it's there in our spreadsheet
i'm going to drag it over a little bit
and then i can come back i'll get out of
that one i'll come back to explore and
see what some of the other charts are
we've got a line graph it talks about
donations increasing
we've got this little stacked bar graph
december 2017 has the highest value for
donations and a value greater than most
for events
and if we come back up to the top you
see we can even click on
more it'll do you know more of this
and so we come back down here and then
we've got scatter plots
and bar charts and donations went down
in uh 2016
october we get a pie chart
it's it's really kind of amazing and
this is the sort of thing that
as google continues to work on their
products which they
spend a lot of time on there will be
more and more functionality here
and so truthfully when you start working
with your data you may want to go
instead of waiting for the end go at the
beginning to see
what explorer offers you both in terms
of
pre-made charts and even some
suggestions on the interpretation
it might save you some time and give you
additional insights
that you might not have approached
through your own means and so
it's a fabulous fabulous addition to
google sheets
to help make your analysis and your
applications easier
when you've made all of your charts in
google sheets you've got a lot of
different ways that you can get that
information out there
you can share the individual sheets with
people you can save the charts as images
and put them into presentations or
documents
you can copy them and put them onto
websites but i do want to show you
one interesting alternative that works
well because google sheets is in fact a
web application
and that is publishing your charts to
the web
now i'm going to begin with one that
isn't even really a chart
it's this page right here we just want
to publish
this little bit of text based charts
and so let's do this let's just come
right up here to
file and to publish
to the web now what it's going to ask is
whether i want to do the entire document
or just this one page or a particular
page
and what these are actually listing are
graphs on pages i'm just going to pick
this first page
and it's going to ask whether i want to
do it as a web page or save it as a csv
or
tab separated file or a pdf or something
else i'm going to save it as a web page
and i'm going to hit publish it double
checks which is a good thing
and then it gives me this very very
long web address now i'm going to go to
a incognito browser so
it's not logged in for me and i enter
that and go to it
and check it out there is my chart it's
my little
repeat chart and so it you know it's not
well formatted but the point is it's
there and it's a way of getting the
stuff
out immediately let's try a different
one
i'm going to go back to where i was i'm
going to close this one
and let's come down here to the line
chart
and i'm going to come down to this
bottom one because i've got several
different lines on it
so this might be the sort of thing that
you want to share with other people
i'm going to hit these three buttons
right here and that also gets me to the
published chart i could do it from the
file menu as well
i'm going to hit publish chart revenue
by source by month
and i have an option of making it
interactive or making it a static image
i'm going to do this one as an image
and by the way you can see down here is
telling me that the repeat
chart is published also i'm going to hit
publish
it's going to check with me again that's
good and i'm going to copy this address
and i'll go back to this page open up a
new tab
paste it in and now you can see
it's a web page it's up here on
docs.google.com
and it's a little fuzzy because it
actually is
low resolution it's about 500 by 300
pixels i don't know why it's that small
but it's available to people and people
can copy this url and have access to the
document
now i want to go a third choice
and that is let's come over to the
timeline because i've got this
same data about revenue sources
revenue streams and i'm going to take
this more complex one
now one of the cool things about
timelines is that they
are by nature interactive you can come
here say i want just the
last one year i want the last six months
of course it's going to bring up this
editing window so i'll slide things over
and you've got this little slider right
here you can use as a way of changing
the
time frame you're dealing with that's
all very cool
so let's come up to these three little
dots and say publish the chart
now the last one i did as an image this
one i'm going to make
interactive so i'm going to hit publish
it's going to ask me if i want to do
that
i'm going to copy that address so it's
already highlighted
go to my other page open a new tab and
put the address in there
and what you'll find is it actually
doesn't look exactly the way it was
before
it's arranged a little differently so
for instance these three sources are
listed
on the left as opposed to across the top
but you do get the numbers as you
go through and you do have the zoom
thing this is still available but we've
lost
the thing to drag across the bottom the
timeline selector which is unfortunate
because that's one of the best ways of
interacting
so not perfect not complete but it is a
really nice way to share
things by just giving people a web page
give them a link
and they can start interacting with your
data in certain
ways and start getting some of the same
insights out of it that you had
now i want to finish with one little
thing here i'm going to close these
three tabs and that is once you have
stuff published
you know the time may come you don't
want it to be out there anymore
and so what you need to do is come down
here this is showing us what's published
now we can't scroll up very much here
but you see
the check marks next to the things that
are published just hit
stop publishing
and those links will no longer be active
and this stuff is back in your private
control
so publishing is one interesting
not perfect but an interesting method of
getting your information out there
sharing your message sharing your data
and then being able to
get insight from the people around you
when people think about computers and
data a lot of times they think about
things like
machine learning and these artificial
intelligence algorithms that do these
incredibly complicated things but it
turns out
that the vast majority of tasks that we
need to do with data
are simple arithmetic addition and
subtraction
multiplication and division and these
are really easy to do in google sheets
with formulas but one thing we need to
get started with is
cell references so when you're writing a
formula
you need to have google sheets refer to
the right
cell and you can do this with what are
either called relative references or
absolute references and i'll demonstrate
both we'll begin with
relative references what i have here is
a list of the numbers 1 through 10
and i want to take each of those numbers
and i want to multiply it times
2 and i'm going to start by writing a
formula all i do is i
type equals that tells google sheets i'm
going to write a formula
and then i click on the cell i want to
multiply it's 1
over to the left and i to multiply it
times 2 i do
asterisk 2. great and when i do that you
can see a preview of what these
answer is going to be i just hit it and
there's a 2.
if you want to see again what's going on
here just double click on this cell
and it will highlight the cell it's
referred to and you see the color here
is orange and it matches here
if you have more than one cell reference
it'll do them in different colors
but you can see that there's a formula
there and then i'm going to click on
that one
and i'm going to drag it down and what
it's going to do is it's going to
maintain the relative reference and it's
going to say
at each step take the cell that is
one over to the left and multiply it
times two
if you want to see what all the formulas
look like you can do
control tilde where the tilde on the us
keyboard is above the tab
and that shows you all the formulas you
see it goes to a3 to a4 to a5 so on down
to a12
and multiply times 12. that's a relative
reference because all it says is
go one to the left it doesn't say go to
column a
although it has an a written here but it
just is interpreted as
the next one to the left
now there's other ways to do it you
don't have to refer just to the left let
me turn off the
view formulas you may want to do a
running total in which case we do a
combination of things
first i'm going to write a formula that
says copy this one right here
that's the simplest possible formula and
then for each
subsequent formula i'm going to say take
the number that's right above
and to that add the number that's to
the left okay so
one above and add one to the left and if
i take that and drag it down
you'll see that in each point it's
taking the number that's immediately
above and the number that's immediately
to the left and adding them up and i get
a running total
of by the time i get to the bottom here
110.
that actually is a useful thing to do if
you are keeping track safe for instance
of invoices
and you need to know the total
expenditures doing this running total
is actually how you would do it and
relative references
will be useful for that one on the other
hand sometimes
you say don't just go one to the left or
one above but you need to tell it to
refer
to a specific column or a specific row
even when
you're moving things around that's where
you get the idea of an absolute
reference
now i'm going to multiply numbers in
this little table and i'll show you
really how not to do it we'll start by
saying i'm going to type in equals to
say it's a formula we'll take
1 to the left and i'll type an asterisk
to multiply and i'll do it
1 to the top okay 1 times 2
is easy but watch what happens if i drag
that down
it's not going to do 5 times 2 here it's
doing 5 times 6 and if i drag that all
to the right
then i end up with some really big
numbers instead of
this should be 30 down here instead of 3
million
and so that's not what we want to do i'm
going to back that up
instead i need to tell it that when it
goes to the left it needs to
always go to column e
and when it goes to the top it needs to
always go to row 2.
but even though it always goes to column
e it will sometimes need to go to
this number or this number or this
number depending on the row it's in
so we're going to do a combination of
relative and absolute references
and the way to tell it to always go to
one particular column or one particular
row
is to use a dollar sign
on the us keyboard that's above the four
and that says always go to e although it
can
adjust the row and over here it says you
can adjust the column but
always go to row number two
and when i do that watch what happens i
can drag that
and now it works the way i want to so if
i click on this one you can see it's
multiplying that number and that number
if i click on this one it's doing that
number and that number
and if i do this cell it's going the 6
times 5 which is 30.
and so that's one way to do it now by
the way there is a more sophisticated
way of using something called an array
formula here
but that's a special circumstance and
i'm not going to get into that
and there's one other situation where
you may want to use absolute references
on both dimensions now what i'm going to
do is i'm going to recreate this table
here
by simply saying equals then i'll come
up here
and i'm going to copy all those values
these are relative references by the way
and there we go so i've got them all
there but i want to
multiply each of these numbers times 10
which means it always has to go to
exactly this cell which is e8
and so what i need to do is i click on
this formula here
and i write an asterisk to do
multiplication i'm going to click on
this cell
e8 but then i'm going to put a dollar
sign before the e
and a dollar sign before the 8.
and then when i drag it down it will
always refer to that specific cell
when doing the multiplication so for
instance if i click right here
you can see it's taking that number
multiplying it times that
here it's doing the relative reference
up to here but the absolute reference to
this cell
and the same thing here relative
reference to this one but
always referring to this one back and so
that's the combination of
absolute and relative references the way
that you combine them
gives you more flexibility in how you
create your formulas
and more power in how you set up your
analyses
some of the most useful things you can
do in a spreadsheet are also
the most basic so i want to show you
some of the most important formulas
that you'll use most often to get the
first steps of insight out of your data
the three that i want to show you with
one variation on them
are count and sum and mean
account is used to simply decide how
many
values you have in front of you it's
getting your sample size
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take this series of dates here
and i've imagined like we have a yoga
studio and we've got the number of
people
attending a group class on each day now
please note
one of these is not a number it's text i
wrote down because the fourth of july is
a holiday in the u.s
but let's do this first one which is
count now
i can do this two different ways i can
type equals and then the word count
but because this is one of the basic
formulas
there's a shortcut to it if i come right
up here
this is a greek sigma that's the
summation sign
if i simply say count it inserts
equals count and then the parentheses
and it simply wants to know what
data should it count and i'm going to
drag
click and drag over these numbers
and when i hit return i get 13.
so there are 13 numbers here the thing
to remember about count is it only
counts
how many numbers there are so it ignored
this piece of text on the other hand
there may be situations
where you need to include even written
things you need to include
any kind of information that's in the
cell and in that case you're going to
want to use a small variation called
count
a you can think of count a as count
all not just numbers but everything and
this one i am going to type out i'm
going to put equals
and then i'm going to type in count a
and that pops up right there so i can
click on that and then i'm going to
click and drag over the data
and then i'm going to put a closing
parenthesis and hit return
and that tells us that there are 14
values within
this range of data there are 13
numbers within that range but there are
14
values 14 cells that have something in
them
so counting can be very important just
for counting
how many entries you have even more
useful is going to be
adding things up some and summing's
really easy to do
i'm going to put my cursor right here
select that cell
then i'm going to come back up and hit
sum
and it simply wants to know what data to
add up so i'm going to click and drag
over these
and i have a sum of 170 so
over 14 days we had 13 classes at the
yoga studio and we had a total
of 170 people show up which raises the
next
question if we had 170 people show up
over
13 classes what's the average number of
people per class
now there's two ways to do this one is
to simply
take this sum and divide it by the count
that is the definition of a mean but i
can also use the built-in formula for
mean
which is nice because it's going to
ignore for instance that piece of text
in there as well
so i'm simply going to have this cell
come over here and click average the
average and the mean
in most situations refer to the same
thing it's where you get a
total of the number of people the amount
of money the amount of time and you
divide it by
the number of cases you're distributing
it across
i'm going to hit average and then simply
drag over these numbers hit return
and that tells me that i have an average
of 13.1 people
in each class period obviously sometimes
it's higher sometimes it's lower we go
from 7
to 21 but an average of 13 and so
these are very simple operations simply
counting how many numbers you have
adding them up and getting the average
but you're also going to find those are
going to give you an enormous amount of
insight
the simple operations are most often the
most effective
in getting meaning out of your data and
these simple
arithmetic procedures are very simple to
do with the built-in functions in google
sheets
more than anything a spreadsheet like
google sheets is a container
for data and one of the important things
to remember is that data comes in
lots of different forms a lot of it's
numerically based
but even then you can format it in many
different ways and there is also
non-numeric data and google sheets can
handle
a huge amount of this and i want to show
you some of those variations
so you know what you can put in and
adapt to your own purposes
the most obvious one of course is just
plain old numbers
like this integer 1587. you put those in
there
google sheets will usually put them
flush right text is usually
flush left you can type those in you can
get
a lot out of just those kinds of
counting
numbers on the other hand you can also
get proportions which are
red like percentages so this is 0.87
is the same as 87 percent in fact if you
want to see it
as a percentage you can just take that
proportion
and you can click here on the format as
percent key and there it is it even
gives you two decimal places
but it's obviously 87 percent
you also have the option of just typing
it in as
87 i'll do it like this
and that also works as a percent if i
press the percent sign there now you see
how it works
now there's one thing you don't want to
do and that is type in the number 87 and
then think if you do this it's going to
turn it into 87
it turns it into 8700 which is obviously
not what you want so you need to start
with a proportion the 0.87
and it turns it into percentages
you can also put in the number like pi
and you can decrease the decimals which
is good because
pi has infinite decimals so we can make
a little smaller if you want
or if you have a number with a lot of
decimals already entered
and i'm using the pi function here you
can increase the decimals i don't know
that you really need a lot more but
they're available if you want them now
often
the information you're going to be
entering into a spreadsheet is going to
be financial you can have money you're
going to be keeping track of
purchases and payments and you have
several different options
one is the accounting format so if
you're an accountant you're familiar
with this
but you come up to format to number
and then come down here to accounting
and
what it does is it puts the comma in for
the thousands
it puts the dollar sign way over here
okay
that's pretty easy you can also do
financial formatting which is
similar in certain ways i'll come down
here
and you'll see it puts in the comma but
otherwise it
doesn't have the dollar sign and it
formats a little bit differently
and there's also currency and
you can set your local currency in
google sheets i'm going to use
dollars that's where i am and so you can
see now it puts a little bit differently
and it's three different ways of
representing the same information
now i realize they're slightly different
from each other
it becomes a little more pronounced when
you make the numbers negative
so i'm going to put a negative there and
now you see it puts it in parentheses
that's a common thing in accounting
and with financial it also puts it in
parentheses but when i come to currency
and i put a negative
it sticks it in front of the dollar sign
so a few different ways of dealing with
money depending on
what's the most common practice in the
work that you do
you can also put in dates you just type
them in
16 it'll format them and then i'll show
you in another video
there's a lot you can do with dates in
google sheets
and you can also use time so for
instance 10 10 31 just enter it
as hours and then colon minutes colon
and
seconds so those are all numbers and
there's a lot of things you can do with
numbers
but google sheets is able to handle a
lot more than that it's able to handle
well for instance it can handle text
so you can just type in words and it
turns out there's a lot of functions
that allow you to deal with words and
i'll give you examples of those in a
later movie you can put in web links
if you type in a valid web address i
just typed in datalab.cc my address
it recognizes that as http
although it should be https because i
have an ssl
certificate and those are live links you
can click on them
and it'll take you there so here for
instance i have
my website datalab now opening because i
had it
here in the cell the same thing works
you can put email addresses in there
it'll work a lot of different ways
you can put web data this is an
interesting one
this is a special function that calls in
google finance data so this is today's
stock price
for google 1066 dollars a share
and by the way notice we get this little
uh
disclaimer down here at the bottom if i
were to delete that the disclaimer would
go away
of course you can use formulas and i've
used a few of them already and have a
lot more say about
formulas so for instance the formula
that pulls up this data is
google finance and then in parentheses
and
uh quotation marks goog because that's
the symbol for google and
financial markets and one other
interesting thing you can do in google
sheets that you can't do
in every spreadsheet is you can include
images now this is an image that
is on the web it's my company logo and
you do
image and then you put the url for that
image in quotes
nice thing is if i make this cell bigger
that you know it increases in size as
well so
you can put an image in a cell if you
can link it
from a url i'm going to put that one
back to where it was
and then finally you have the option of
including
floating images and a number of other
things let me give you an example of
that
i'm going to come right here to insert
you can put in a chart an
image a drawing a form check boxes
comments and i'll talk about a lot of
those
let me just insert an image for right
now the one thing you need to know
when you include an image i'm just going
to get one off on my desktop
i got my datalab icon
the one thing you need to know is that
it's a floating image and so it's not
in the cell you can drag it around it's
also really big i'm going to make it
smaller
so it's not linked to the cell and
that's a little different from this web
image that we have
in the cell but it is possible to
include this information
especially if you're trying to build up
a repository or even have sort of a
branding with your
spreadsheets it gives you many different
options
and so what you can see from all of this
is that google sheets
is able to serve as a container for a
lot of different
kinds of data each of which might arise
in different circumstances
in your own work numbers are
probably what come to mind for most
people when they think about
spreadsheets and that's
reasonable because i'm willing to bet
that most spreadsheets are in fact
filled with numbers but
spreadsheets are more powerful than that
and more flexible
they can use text as well which is good
because when you're working in an
organizational setting chances are
you're going to have to work with a lot
of
text like people's names and their
addresses and what their last orders
were
and the nice thing is you can work with
that
i want to show you a few specific
functions that can be very helpful in
particular dealing with names
in google sheets so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to
show you these using the name ruth saint
dennis now if you don't know
ruth saint dennis she's one of the
founders of american modern dance
and even though her name looks like it
should be pronounced ruth sandini
she's american so it's saint dennis
the first thing we want to do is simply
find out how
many characters there are in a cell and
that's a really simple one
because we have a function called len
for length
and it counts the number of letters
and spaces and punctuation so we have 14
pieces of information in this particular
cell
great that's a starting point for a lot
of other things now we might be looking
for a particular piece of text and in
this case i'm going to look for the
first
space because for a lot of people that's
going to separate their first name from
their last name
and the function i use for that is
called find
you simply need to tell it what is
you're trying to find and i have
quotation marks with a space that i put
in between them says
find the first space in this cell and
return
its location which is a number and it's
five because we have ruth is one two
three four letters and the space is the
fifth
thing in that particular cell next
we want to select the text up to the
first blank that is get her first
name and the way we're going to do that
is with the function
left left says start at the left in this
cell
and go how far i'm saying five
characters and the reason i know five
is because that's what we got when we
were looking for the first blank here
and we do that we get her first name
ruth
now to get her last name i'm going to
say
get everything else now because
14 which is the total length minus 5
which is where the first space is 14
minus 5 is 9.
i'm going to simply do that this one
however is going to be starting from the
right
and so i use the function right it says
go to the end of this cell and then
count back to the left nine spaces that
gets us to the
s in saint dennis and there's her first
name
also a lot of times when you get
information in your
spreadsheet it might be a little weird
you might have spaces where they
shouldn't be i have spaces before the
name
after the name and you often want to
clean those things up so things work a
little better
so for instance i have ruth st dennis
here and
you may not be able to tell but there
are three spaces before her name
and there are also three spaces after
her name so we're going to get rid of
those
by using the function developed
specifically for this called
trim and it gets rid of all of the
leading
and trailing spaces and so now we have
ruth saint denis
without the stuff before after now you
may have guessed that it's possible to
combine
all of these in a logical algebra for
processing text
so for instance maybe you have people
entering their names
all in one cell when they're filling out
a form on your web page
so here i have ruth st dennis i want to
split it into her first name and last
name because that's how i want to store
it in my database
i can combine these functions and this
is going to be a little complicated
but here's how it works i get ruth
but the way i got it was by first saying
go to cell b9 that's where the name is
go to the left and then find
the first space in that cell
and then trim everything that comes
after it and when i do that
i get ruth if i want just her last name
i can use the complement of that and in
this case
it looks like this we're going to do a
combination of get the right which is
how we got the last name but we have to
do the length of the whole cell
minus the space up to the first space
and then we trim
the extra stuff at the end and so yeah
there's a lot of parentheses here and
it's a little complicated which is why
i actually do use this formula i have a
database with names in it
and i do this to rearrange the way they
come in natively
so that they make more sense to me and
so i have to use all this stuff but
i tell you it takes me a few minutes to
get it all
worked out but then i just copy it drag
it down and it takes care of everything
in the spreadsheet
it's really nice on the other hand what
if things come
last name comma first name well then you
simply do a
little bit of rearranging in this case
you're going to do the trimming you're
simply switching what we had here to
over here
that's quick and easy you're searching
for the
comma in this case and you're getting
the stuff that
it comes after the comma but trimming
the spaces
and then the last one is for the last
name you do have to make
one small modification here and that is
you have to tell it we're going to find
the comma
we're going to get the left part but you
need to include this minus 1 to adjust
the selection because you're doing
from the comma and then you trim the
blank spaces and then you have
what you need and so all of these are
different functions in fact let me turn
on the
variable view the function view and now
you can see what's going on
as a way of cleaning up organizing
getting the information
you need so you can stick it in your own
customer database
and get it set up so you can then
process it
using other functions that can combine
text and numbers and whatever else you
need
to suit your purposes one of the neat
tricks you can do
in a spreadsheet like google sheets is
you can use formulas not only to
look at numbers or even to select text
but to start combining text with
calculations which is sort of like doing
a
form fill on a letter but it gives you a
lot more control and flexibility
i want to show you a few different ways
of combining
information they all accomplish the same
thing
but they give you different approaches
to it
and depending on how many items you're
using you might want to choose one or
the other
i use all of these in my own work let's
go back to this
fictional example of say for instance a
yoga studio
and you've got seven days here and
you're keeping track of attendance
in the group yoga classes so you got 31
on monday
26 on tuesday things drop off by
thursday you're down to seven then
people feel
bad and they start showing up they're on
the weekend
and so you have 134 people total
showing up in those seven days but let's
find out
how you can use some special functions
in google sheets
to combine that into a report so i'm
going to come over here for a moment
and i'm going to paste in a little bit
of information first let's put in the
beginning of a sentence you had a total
of
and then we're going to put a formula
here
now this formula is simply referring
to this data over here it's just the sum
it's the same formula that's down here
okay so we've got that but now let's
put the second part of a sentence i'm
going to turn off the formula display
here for a moment
you had a total of 134 visitors this
week and so
what this is is some text
a number that's derived from a formula
and then a little more text we want to
put them all together into a single
sentence now we've got a few ways to do
this
the first one is with this now here's
you see there's a problem with this one
by the way
what i've done is i've simply said use
this cell
and this cell and this cell so you use
the
and sign the ampersand to get from one
to the other
that's great except as you can tell it
doesn't put
spaces in and so you need to add the
spaces
manually and the way you do that
is by inserting two more parts here
you put in quotes with a space and so it
says
take this first cell add a space add the
second cell
add a space add the third cell and so
that works and
that can be a useful way of combining
the information and making sure it's
formatted
the way you want to it looks like a
proper sentence and it's not clear to
people that you're actually doing
some math to make these things happen
another way to do it
is to actually include the formula in
there itself because in this one
i'm using the sum that comes from up
here this one i'm including a formula
that refers back to the original
column so there may be times when you
want to do the calculations
in your sentence or you simply want to
refer to the calculations that are done
elsewhere
obviously the result is identical
another option is to use the sentences
right there in the cell itself so let me
highlight this one this time i'm typing
you had a total of and i'm including the
space in there
then i put the ampersand then i put the
formula sum
and then ampersand the and sign and then
quote and i include the space here and
then visitors this week
and so the only thing that's going on
here is i'm inserting
that sum that makes it possible to get
the rest of the information
and then there are two other ways that
we can do this there's a special
function
called join and when you use
join what it does is it
lets you specify the cells you want to
put together
and the thing you want to stick in
between each cell
in this case i'm putting quotes with a
space
and then comma and say join this one and
this one and this one i could also use
d2 colon f2 to specify the range
but it's a really quick and easy way
sometimes when you have a lot of things
to put together
the join statement is going to be easier
although i find the
and statement where you're using the and
sign can be a little clearer about
what's going on
and then finally one other option is to
use
join but to this time have the formula
for the sum right
in here so it's a self-contained
statement so it's referring
to this one joining with that joining
with that
anyhow you can use ampersands the and
sign
as long as you remember to put a space
in
by putting quote space quote
or you can use join either one allows
you to combine
text along with calculations based on
the information
i use this a lot in spreadsheets as a
way of creating a sort of
mail merge i use it to create the
subject lines for emails to have
boilerplate text for emails and so i
just have to copy one
paste it into the subject copy a second
paste it into the text
and i'm good to go and it's based on a
whole series of calculations combining
text
that's in my spreadsheet so it gives you
extra flexibility and extra power
to work with different kinds of data to
get it to best
fit with your particular need formulas
in google sheets can be used
not only to multiply numbers
or to select text or to combine things
like that
they can also be used to do some basic
formatting
and what's really nice about this is you
can use these
conditional formats which are formula
based formats
to highlight data bring your attention
for instance to things that are
performing very well very poorly
issues that need to be resolved i use
them frequently to help me
find open cases and let me just show you
quickly how this works start by
selecting the text that you want to
format so for instance i'm going to come
here
to teacher now this is something i could
do easily on my own
but if you had a very long list you
wouldn't want to do this manually
let's highlight a particular teacher and
so
what i do is i select this text and then
i come over to format
and down to conditional formatting
that's going to open up a little window
here on the side
and it's going to apply to this range
c3 through c9 that's the range i have
selected here
and we're going to tell it well right
now it says
cell is not empty well they all have
stuff in them
i'm going to say instead that the text
contains and then i'm going to put the
name
of one of the teachers emanuel we have
kofi alex and emmanuel
and i'm just going to leave this default
i can change the color if i want by
clicking on one of these
i don't need to i'm going to hit done
and now
if a manual's name pops up as the
teacher
then it automatically gets highlighted
and if i were to change one of the other
cells to save manual
it would automatically inherit that in
fact let's do that right here
let's change this one to say
i gotta spell it correctly emmanuel you
see it inherits
the conditional formatting
next is what if i want to highlight not
just that person's name
but the entire row that they're in this
is actually
what i use i use a spreadsheet as a
large database for
assigning teachers to classes and when a
class isn't assigned it says staff
but i want the whole row to highlight
and so i'm going to select
this entire rectangle of data so not
just the teacher
but also the attendance and the dates
i'm going to get the whole
bit of information then i'm going to
come over to conditional formatting
i'm going to add a new rule and the rule
i'm going to add
is a slightly funny one you may not
guess this one
i actually have to come down here to
custom
formula and what i want to tell it to do
is
if the teacher is emmanuel then
highlight the entire row
and it goes counter-intuitively like
this
i write equals and then the dollar sign
seeds say
always look at column c
and then 13 is there because that's the
first row in the block
and then if that cell is equal to
a manual and because it's text i have to
put it in quotes then highlight it
and so that's what we've got right here
i hit done
and you see how it's highlighted and
again if we were to change another's
name to emmanuel
you see how the entire row inherits that
highlighting
and again this is really useful for
identifying
important clients it's for identifying
unassigned cases
it's useful for identifying any number
of situations that you can describe with
a formula
and then finally another good one is
what's called
a color scale i'm going to come over
here where i
have the information again i'm going to
select just the attendance information
and i'm going to select a new rule here
now not a single color which is what
i've been doing so far but a color
scale and what this does is it lets me
choose a range of colors
that go from the minimum value through
the midpoint up to the maximum
now i don't want the green to be the low
and i'm going to switch it the other way
around i've got some choices here
i'm going to pick this one so it goes
from white to
green and it highlights the higher
values i'm going to hit done and what
you can see now is that
the darkest green is on the day that we
had 31 people
the white is for the lowest value which
in this
set is 12. and so it can give you an
impression of the range of the data
and again maybe things you need to focus
on maybe you need to figure out what's
going on the low days maybe you need to
figure out what you can do to increase
the high days but conditional formatting
in any of these situations with the
color scale
with highlighting a single cell with
highlighting an entire row
is a way of using formulas again not
just
to manipulate numbers or to manipulate
text but to manipulate
the highlighting and drawing attention
through additional visual cues and it
makes it a lot easier to work with your
data
and find the things that you need to
make sense
congratulations you've made it to the
final video in
google sheets and you may be wondering
what to do
next well i'm here to discuss a couple
of possible next steps for you
in learning to work with data and in
learning to work with google sheets
the most important thing is to do it
yourself get
started and get mixed in with things
you want to get some data and you just
want to try see how things work in
google sheets
you can do a little bit experimenting a
little feeling around see how it behaves
and what you can get out of it to serve
your own purposes
now what you're going to need to do is
get some data
now chances are you already have some
data
where you work you may have if you're in
an organization that does email
marketing you'll have the names and the
email addresses and location information
maybe information about open rates and
click-throughs on your email
newsletters that's a great place to get
data you can download that from your
email service provider
you may have social media data things
like
who's following you who's commenting
where they are
when they last interacted what they said
and
how they connected and how they shared
things and what they really believed
about all of it
this is information that is also
available to you through the analytics
of your
social media host like if you're using
buffer or hootsuite you can get this
information and start putting it into
google sheets and see what you can do
also you may have sales data or some
other kind of
interaction you might know what kind of
items people are buying or what services
they're requesting whether a first time
or a repeat customer
and also the path to purchase did they
click on a thing in instagram and get to
facebook and get to your web page
and that is a lot of information that
can be very helpful
for businesses and for service
organizations
to start better understanding how people
are interacting with them and how they
can reach out
if you have that data available to you
download it
see what you can do with it in google
sheets
beyond what you can do with the built-in
analytics of
each of these programs also you can get
free data
for instance data.gov is one of the best
sources of open data in the united
states
you can search for a lot of other
different sources here i'm showing i
went to data.gov
and i typed in the word art i'm looking
for data sets on art
i have over 11 000 data sets found and
you know
you just click on this little csv which
stands for comma separated values
that'll download a spreadsheet that you
can open up in google sheets and you can
get started with open data
you can also get data from google trends
and that's
a service from google that lets you see
over time
the relative popularity of different
search terms here i've got two
german operas deflator mouse and derozan
cavalier
and you can see that for instance the
second one was more popular
back in may of 2017 but the first one's
been more popular since then
you can download that data by clicking
on this button right here
and start seeing what you can do with it
in your own
analysis finally there's google
correlate one of my favorite services
that lets you look at
the popular search terms over time like
we had with google trends
but it also lets you look at state by
state comparisons
where it gives you number in terms of
the actually its standard deviations
of each state in terms of the relative
popularity of a search term within that
state
one of my favorite ones here is the
search for modern dance
and you can get that information you can
download it right here by clicking on
csv
and just in case you're wondering the
state that is head and shoulders above
every other in the entire united states
in terms of searches for modern dance
is right here in utah where i live it's
one of the more shocking things in terms
of
data driven insights
now there's other things that you can
learn and i
suggest that if you start here with
google sheets you might want to try to
learn some
more things so for instance here at data
lab cc
available either right now or in the
near future
our courses on data principles i've been
showing you the
tools and i've been showing you how to
work the tools but the concepts
what does it mean to do a regression
what does it mean to have a standard
deviation
i'm going to talk about those things in
these other courses
i also have sets of courses on the other
applications within the google drive
office suite
so that's things like google docs for
preparing reports
and google slides for making
presentations google forms for gathering
new data through online surveys and of
course
there's the microsoft office complement
of all of those
excel and powerpoint and word
in addition to those if you decide that
you need more than a spreadsheet can do
easily for you you might want to try
statistical
software i suggest
jamovi a new and not very well known but
immensely wonderful application that you
can download
upload your csv and start doing high
quality statistical analyses it's free
it's open source it's based on r but it
operates with drop down menus that make
analysis very easy
also spss is a common choice in a lot of
different fields in nursing
and education in the social sciences we
have courses on sbss and if that's the
one that's most common in your field
try to get your data into that and see
what kind of statistical modeling you
can do there as well
and then of course if you want to go
beyond that you could try statistical
programming
in languages like r and python we have
our first course in r currently
available python will soon follow
and in any of these you're going to be
able to build on what you've done in
google sheets the
the inside that you've gone and you'll
be able to build on it to get more
statistical modeling more predictive
analytics
more ways of finding what you need and
so
it's time to get moving get some data
get going i'm so grateful that you
joined us here at datalab.cc i hope this
has been
an eye-opening experience and an
opportunity for you
to get working with your data to find
ways that you can run
your organization your business and your
own personal projects
more effectively and more efficiently
thanks for joining me
and good luck